okay stand by it's uh 9 30 we'll be
rolling in just a moment
foreign
folks it is uh zero nine thirty plus
this being veterans committee we will uh
try to more than any other committee
um try to be on time as much as possible
because this is veterans committee
um representative baldacero the previous
chair would always start a session or a
hearing with the Pledge of Allegiance
and so uh there was a flag right behind
me so if you wouldn't mind standing
and I'll start this
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
right thank you uh so first up today is
HB 206 including space force and various
definitions of the Armed Forces there is
one sponsor that's representative Roy I
do not see representative Roy yet or
here he's the sole sponsor so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to introduce
the bill so that we can we have several
people who signed up to speak to it
so HP 206 including space force and
various definitions of the Armed Forces
so in our statute
relevant statute that's RSA 4 colon 13
Dash
I uh it simply entails adding you know
say space force to the five existing
branches that are listed in our statute
those being in order uh U.S Air Force
U.S army United States Coast Guard
United States Navy and essays Marine
Corps
and
there are two other spots it simply adds
space force and statute along with those
other five branches in our existing
statute and that is the essence of
HB 206
again not seeing representative Roy here
um I do have a request from Melissa
Willett Melissa's in the house yes
so Melissa at this time if you'd like to
approach the uh
I don't want to call it the witness
stand I guess that's the Testify the
testimony location and hit the red
button and and welcome to state federal
and veterans
thank you very much chairman
uh thank you representative Roy for the
introduction to the bill and Mr Perry
for being here today chairman Moffett
Vice chairman Rollins and distinguished
members of the state federal relations
and Veterans Affairs committee I am
Melissa Willette New England Regional
liaison for the United States Department
of Defense State liaison office and I'm
here today to testify in favor of the
policies reflected in House Bill 206
adding space force to the various
definitions of armed forces in the New
Hampshire revised statutes
by clearly defining Armed Forces to
include the space force the state of New
Hampshire can minimize disruptions and
benefits and services for eligible
service members and their dependents
this is because when state laws align
with federal laws it ensures that
service members and their families have
access to the same benefits and service
Services no matter where they are
stationed
updating the definition of military
service in the state of New Hampshire to
include the space force will also ensure
that service members and their families
have a smooth transition when they move
to the state this is particularly
important for active duty service
members and their families who are
required to move frequently
on December 20th 2019 Congress enacted
the United States space force act which
established the United States space
force as an armed Force within the
department of the Air Force its primary
mission is to organize train and equip
military personnel for space operations
and defend the United States interest in
space
as a result of this change as you were
likely aware New Hampshire became home
to New Boston space force station in
Hillsborough County which spreads across
the towns of New Boston Amherst and
Mount Vernon New Boston space force
station is operated by the 23rd space
operations Squadron which maintains the
largest satellite control Network remote
tracking station in the world along with
command and control capability for the
global positioning system
House Bill 206 is not only key to the
Readiness and retention of the service
members serving at New Boston space
force station but to those current and
former space force Guardians stationed
elsewhere who call the granite state
home
space force is the First new branch of
the Armed Forces in over seven decades
this requires states to consider
modifying their policies to ensure their
definition reflects this change in force
structure which will minimize
disruptions and benefits and services
for space force Guardians as well as
their families
adding this branch of service to the New
Hampshire revised statute's definition
of armed forces will ensure that
military families are equally
represented under all New Hampshire laws
which Define military service military
retiree and Veteran and that all
Guardians receive the benefits and
resourcing they have earned through
their service
for example this legislation also
clarifies that military family care
providers certified by the Department of
Defense or the military services
including the space force May provide
child care to the children of military
families off the installation which may
Benefit Service members housed in the
Portsmouth region who are assigned to
Naval Shipyard Portsmouth to put it
simply by updating the definition of
armed forces to include the space force
the state of New Hampshire will be able
to ensure that service members and their
families have access to the same
benefits and services as they would at
any other Duty station and that they are
not unfairly impacted by state laws that
do not reflect Federal changes
failure to act could make it more
difficult to attract highly skilled
individuals to the branch this would
limit the talent pool available to the
space force and could make it more
difficult to fill critical vacancies not
including the space force and the
definition of armed services in the
state of New Hampshire could also
negatively impact Readiness and
resiliency
service members and their families who
are not provided with the same benefits
and services as those in other branches
of the military may not be as prepared
for deployments and other operations
without access to the same benefits and
services service members may be more
likely to leave the military
the granite state has a rich tradition
of military service and Veteran advocacy
New Hampshire provides a wide array of
benefits and preferences to Veterans
living in the state as well as their
dependents in addition to those which
they may be entitled to under federal
laws and regulations the policies in
House Bill 206 when passed will afford
the Guardians of the space force the
same entitlements as well as their
families
New Hampshire's military veterans
service members and their families make
significant contributions to our
communities and our Workforce and the
Department of Defense remains committed
to working with our partners on the
local state and federal levels to
recognize the sacrifices they make on
our behalf on behalf of the under
secretary of defense for personnel and
Readiness and the deputy assistant
secretary of defense for military
community and family policy as a service
member and Military Spouse myself I am
grateful to the committee for all of
your hard work past and present on
behalf of those who have served and I
would like to thank the bill sponsor
representative Terry Roy Major General
michelaides and yourself chairman for
your long and faithful military service
and your strong advocacy on our behalf
I'd be happy to answer any questions you
may have at this time
thank you miss Lynn thank you for
offering to take questions I have just a
real quick one for you uh so you're
representing the defense State liaison
office could you describe that office
briefly for us yes sir the dslo is
comprised of eight Regional Liaisons
across the company uh across the country
I represent the New England region and
as a liaison it's my responsibility to
work with State elected officials and
stakeholders to work on issues that
affect military veterans and their
families
thank you uh other questions for for
Melissa
Cena thank you so much for being here in
this snowy morning and for what you do
for the veterans community
okay next up uh Miss Kevin Grady uh
illustrious Air Force uh veterans is it
colonel Grady or Colonel grading uh
welcome back you've been here before
yes sir I have it's uh it's me again I
enjoyed spending time with you last
Friday and uh I'll be spending some time
with you again this morning for for
three bills for the record I am Kevin
Grady I'm a 25-year Air Force veteran
and I'm also a 23-year resident of the
town of Hooksett New Hampshire uh the
the state veterans advisory committee
that I'm representing today they we
fully support this bill we actually did
have the language on it and we voted on
it at our January 3rd meeting and we
were unanimously in support of this and
my position on the state veterans
advisory committee the group I represent
is the Air Force Association which has
recently changed their name to the air
and space forces Association so I'm
acutely aware of of the space force and
and what those folks do and I'm also
aware that to a lot of Americans the
space force is a Steve Carell TV series
on Netflix and you know we need to sort
of let people know that they just
celebrated their third anniversary on
December 20th as a separate service
under the department of the Air Force
very much like the Marines are a
separate service under the department of
the Navy it's the same kind of
relationship so we do support this
legislation you know we do have as a
previous speaker mentioned a new New
Boston space force station in the summer
of 2021 was was moved from being an Air
Force Station to a space force station
they actually have four Guardians
assigned out there there's also about
120 uh civilian contractors and DOD
civilians that that work out at that
place and what they do basically is they
uh they they drive satellites
at that place they control satellites in
space you know every every without
turning this into a less a lesson in uh
in orbital mechanics you know everything
in space is falling and periodically you
have to fire some rockets for a for the
space station or anything in space to
remain in space you got to fire some
rockets and put it back where it belongs
and that's kind of what those folks out
there do
um I was really fortunate in in the fall
of 2021 to take a tour of New Boston
space force station and I highly
recommend that you take the VIP tour out
there sometime you actually go out in
the woods and see parts of the
reservation that used to be an old
bombing range and those kind of things
I'll split the chairman I'll send the
chairman uh Lieutenant Colonel Dave
zezinger who's the commander out there
I'll send you his contact information
and in the spring when the snow melts
you really should go out there and see
that operation it's very it takes a
couple of hours of your time it's a very
impressive thing
um so we do unanimously support this
bill uh and you know anything we can do
to help the space force uh be be a
little bit more known to Americans as a
group that's out there you know part of
our military we we support that it's
subject to your questions that's all I
want to tell you this morning
thank you very much Colonel Grady I have
a quick comment in one question and then
there may be others uh comment is uh so
the New Boston facility is actually uh
in the in New Hampshire is an official
space force station space yes sir space
installation okay and could you take
just a couple few moments for anyone uh
there are folks that are watching from
afar and we'll watch this later who may
have some questions about
um space force I know it's three years
it's been in existed for three years but
uh some folks may be wondering what who
did the functions of that are currently
being done by space force who did those
before and could what was the thinking
behind creating this new Branch if you
could speak to that well the the
uh these were done kind of jointly by
all of the services the Army has a
fairly robust program in Alabama at
redstone Stone Arsenal is where they
they have a group of folks that do a lot
of the same things the Air Force had the
majority of the space assets out in
Colorado Springs and controlled a lot of
the the satellite tracking stations
around the world the commander here also
owns Greenland goes up to Greenland
periodically and and takes a look at at
Satellite so those functions were all
done by a kind of a smattering of each
service had a small part of the pie the
Air Force had the largest part of the
pie which is why they put this under the
Air Force when they created a separate
service but I I think much as
I was back in the post-world War II era
in 1947 when they created the Air Force
as a special as a separate branch of the
military and we came out from under the
department of the army I think that the
thinking was in in Washington that what
we needed was an advocate for space you
know as long as space didn't have its
own you know uh co-equal Branch status
with everybody else that they were sort
of going to get what's left over after
everything was uh was kind of divvied up
and so I think that they wanted somebody
out there that's going to take the lead
for space and space programs so we don't
forget about it and as a personal aside
I used to teach space and space force
things to my junior ROTC students in at
Auburn High School and I told them if if
we can't get your generation as excited
about space travel as I was watching
people walk on the moon back in the
1960s then we're never going to do it
we're never going to invest the money
that it's going to take to do it so
we've got to we've got to keep that in
the press and we've got a and even the
private space stuff that's going out
there you know sending William Shatner
to space keeps people
you know engaged in in in space
operations and so I think that they
wanted somebody to take the lead on that
and that's what we ended up with the
space force
thanks very much for that great answer
uh other questions or anything for
Colonel Grady
Crow Grady would you like to go to space
as uh William Shatner I was convinced I
was going to go to space when I was
younger uh and uh as I used to tell my
students I'm still looking for that
rocket pack we're all supposed to have
that I can drive around on okay so yes I
would I would love to do it someday I
think but maybe maybe my age though it's
the space world has passed me by
Senator Glenn was I think older than you
when he went to school
and I'll bet you were tracking that when
he went to space I was tracking it
absolutely yes sir and most of us have
seen the right stuff more than once um
all right thank you I won't ask if you
have the right stuff but I will thank
you for for your testimony and for being
here thank you sir
okay anyone else uh wishing to speak to
uh HB 206 including space force and
definitions of the Armed Forces locally
if not at this time
that's my historic first gavel strike
will close this hearing and before it
will start the next Hearing in 10
minutes on time at 1000 but
um last week we did a whip around with
the folks who are here just to say who
they were and not everybody could be
here today but I see representative
Lundgren is in the house
and representative Lundgren
um I'd like to invite you to do what the
other folks did last week and take a
couple minutes if you want just to let
us know uh who are we from uh some of
your journey and um
and you have uh 10 minutes if you need
it
I was looking for more like a half hour
if that's possible
no I I'm Dave Lundgren I uh I live in
Londonderry I've been a chiropractor
there for 46 years
um I'm celebrating my start of my sixth
term
with the lovely uh representative
mastermello we came in together
and I've been on this committee for for
10 years and I
really find it uh
helpful in my practice I treat a lot of
vets so it's uh it's good for me to try
to stay on top of things and having met
with the uh Secretary of the VA at one
point regarding an opioid bill that I'm
trying to pass
and uh
so that's pretty much it I'm glad to be
here it's uh
heck of a ride today but
yes thank you beautiful let's look at
that way but yeah and it's wonderful uh
serving unto you guys and
you know that's pretty much it
thank you
thank you representative Lundgren of
Londonderry
okay we still have almost 10 minutes and
we have to uh we have to we cannot start
early
yes
can I add to my diatribe from when we
first met I have a something that is
more in keeping with uh
what I believed in and you know I told
you I was raised in a rough neighborhood
and all that stuff but excuse me
represent Gay Let's see if the committee
will allow you to expand on your diet
do we have does anyone mind if uh
representative uh got any uh adds to his
remarks uh represent money
yes how long will this take
two minutes
two minutes represent Gabby you're
welcome to speak up you have you have
the floor and a
audience on YouTube that could be around
the world I thank you kindly and you
know last time I spoke about many many
many things a rough neighborhood in the
whole bit but I do have some
accomplishments I was never in combat I
joined the Navy in 1981 naval Reserve
here in Manchester
in 1961 and uh
when I came out of boot camp that summer
I was one of the honor guards for Alan
Shepard when he came to used to be
grineer Air Force Base at the time and
so I was 17 years old scared to death I
saw him for about a half a second and my
second claim to fame is I served on the
ship that picked up John Glenn in 62. I
was still in high school at the time but
I served I remember seeing the little
feet stenciled in painted in on this
deck on the deck in a little in a little
plaque that uh
that was there on a ship the USS NOAA
dd841 if you look at the movie if you
watch the movie hidden figures talks
about the Apollo program where John
Glenn ended up going up there and those
three black women who were instrumental
in
making that Apollo program a success
towards the end of the movie for about a
second and a half you'll see John Glenn
being picked up by the USS Noah and
that's the ship I was on
and that's it
two minutes ten seconds you went over
yeah thank you representative gagne
that is fascinating and most of us uh
have some interest in history in Alan
Shepard who you mentioned the first
American in space in 1961 a New
Hampshire a proud New Hampshire uh
Native went to uh Pinkerton Academy in
Derry Pickerton is known as the Astros
and I have asked this nobody's been able
to answer it but yet maybe reps of
London that's your area what was
Pinkerton called before they were the
Astros I I don't know but I'm sure back
in the 30s and 40s they weren't the
Astros
okay
I think it was just Pinkerton Academy
and did not have a nickname they must
have been something
if I have somebody watching on on
YouTube we'll we'll uh let us have that
answer
all right we still have uh six minutes
before we will start uh HB 229 that will
be relative to requiring an official
declaration of war for the activation of
the New Hampshire National Guard
uh in the prime for that I believe is
here will be here
that will be um
representative petusic who I've seen
already this morning
and he is in the house
John yeah join us here
John's on strip alert
represent what Rollins was noting the
gavel it's an emergency gobble it is not
our or my gavel uh representative
Wallace brought in and it is some
history behind this gavel which uh
representative Wallace who's the vice
chair Judiciary can can speak to
yeah uh you can approach uh
representative Kerry our Clerk
representative Finney welcome
um
we did a whip around last week with with
members introducing themselves and
representative Lundgren who is not here
just took a couple of minutes to
introduce himself we have about four
minutes before we can start the next
hearing so I'd like to invite you if you
would like to take a a minute or two
just to uh uh introduce yourself where
you're from and a little bit about your
journey I know you've been on this
Committee in the past
oh there we go oh wait okay so that's
Brandon fitting from Rochester uh it's
my second term I took the last two terms
off
uh happy to be back in the same
committee again I look forward to Harris
monocle five convention bills and uh I'm
so sorry I'm late
but I'm here and uh
I didn't have too much to add really
um except I played a band and you know
do music and politics so
but I'm glad to be here again thank you
for having me
thank you representative Finney
we still have a couple minutes before we
will start right on time at 10 hundred
hours the uh measure of the coming up
before us uh representative petusic will
be introducing it we had a little
conversation ahead of time
um relating to
the notion of uh guard reservists being
activated some of us have been in that
position
I think it was 1968 there was a guard
unit out of New Hampshire that was in
Vietnam and uh just before that unit was
about to return from Vietnam the uh a
tragic uh I think they hit a tried to
hit a land mine we had
um uh as a number of grandstaters who
are just about to return Guardsmen I
believe were just about to return to New
Hampshire who tragically lost their
lives in Vietnam just before these
Guardsmen are about to return to New
Hampshire and of course there was no
official declaration of war at that time
but uh
is someone who's is taught Civics I'm
very much looking forward to
seeing this bill presented hearing the
testimony on this area
and I'm going to round this up to 1000
hours and uh representative patosek if
we'd like to invite you up to uh
introduce hb229
thank you sir
for the record representative John
petusic from Rockingham 13 in Derry
uh
I'm here to present House Bill 229
to your committee
relative to requiring an official
declaration of war for the activation of
the New Hampshire National Guard
I myself am a Vietnam veteran
which precedes
the National Guard being called up for
uh
whatever
and I don't like the whatever
there should be a reason why they're
called up and there should be
justification with the Congress
and Vietnam was a war whether they had a
declaration of war or not it was a war
I have enough friends who are on the
wall in Washington
they died for a Cause
now I was asked to bring this to the
house I was told that last biennium
it did not make it through
so I
I was asked
I asked for co-sponsors
and if memory serves every one of my
co-sponsors on here
is a veteran
we have Army
we have Marine Corps
myself as Air Force
I don't know if we have any costies
but anyway it's all veterans and I
believe that no military body
Air Guard Army guard
should be called out unless there is a
very very substantial reason for them
being called up the declaration of war
is one of them I've heard the fact that
it well you have problems with title 10
or title 32
um
that doesn't wash
so my job today is to present it and
give you a little bit about it
I didn't know a lot about the guard
problem until I got involved in this and
the folks from bring our troops home
sent me this very extremely informative
booklet
born defending the guard and it's now
called the defend the guard bill
so I will take any questions that you
might have and try to answer them
I know for a fact that sitting in front
of me are at least three veterans that I
am very aware of and I'm very good
friends with
and it's probably more
because a lot of us don't show
the fact that we're veterans because in
some
sometimes it's not a good thing but I'm
proud of being a veteran
we're in my air force
a ribbon
and I'm proud of it
I'll take any questions from anybody
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative I have one
quick question and I know we have a
number of pink cards here
uh and I know Warren is he's still here
during a certain
activations or military operations there
is a refueling Wing or not Wing but
refilling unit that has flown out of
peas in New Hampshire that has been
nationalized so to speak to support
Air Force operations so if this measure
were to move forward would this preclude
this unit from being
used for for such uh for such activity I
uh just from uh my perspective
I because I can't speak for anybody
officially
um
I don't think this would interfere with
airguard uh
because
back in the day when I was in Germany
and the outfit I was in was air mobile
and we depended upon uh two two of these
air squadrons one out of Dover Air Force
Base the other out of McGuire Air Force
Base 436 and the 438s air groups to
provide transportation to us wherever we
needed to go uh under orders that came
out of Washington
and they would come over pick us up drop
us off
a week later two weeks later a month
later
they come back pick us up and take us
back to Germany uh where I was and what
I did uh I cannot share
because of the clearances that I had
thank you for that representative
questions uh yet yes representative
massamilo
thank you for taking the question
um under
part it talks about the performance of a
Duty through instrumentality of War what
is that
Ah that's military legalese
it's kind of hard to Define uh for a
civilian Maybe
the the Air Force Major Colonel might be
able to Define that for you but that's
as I used to say that's above my pay
grade
way above mine
it's it's military legalese
other questions for the prime sponsor
representative Finney
and I thank you Mr chair
um I also was in the Army Garden for
about 10 years I was part of a
Detachment whose parent company was out
of the state
um the fiscal no part of this says that
we lose about 400 million dollars in an
annual federal funding would we envision
um units being sent out of the state in
in order to uh
like not like you know cut costs but at
least to save money on you on the state
side because we wouldn't be getting
Federal funding anymore well I I looked
at this and I'm going in
my opinion is that if the federal
government calls you up the federal
government should be paying for it not
the state of New Hampshire
I mean we we have the guard and we have
the drills we have the programs that we
do in State uh and the emergencies that
we do in state but if the feds call you
up the FED should be paying the bill
thank you
for the questions
seeing on thank you petusic prime
sponsor
next we have uh representative mannion
from this committee wants to speak uh
for the bill
sure sure that's uh representative
Senator Stiles oh
thank you representative uh
so so we're upside man you're you're
def okay uh uh representative you have
the uh you have the concert okay
all right
all right thank you uh chairman and
members of the state and Veterans
Affairs committee I'm representative San
anastaso representing Rindge Jaffrey in
Dublin and also I served in the 82nd
Airborne Division as a combat medic and
it was awarded a combat medic badge for
providing Medical Care Under Fire
this bill requires an official
declaration of war uh for the activation
in New Hampshire National Guard and to
put the National Guard uh in compliance
with the Constitution of the United
States article one section 8 of the
United States Constitution vests in
Congress the uh exclusive power to
declare war
so there's two ways National Guardsmen
can be called into uh service under U.S
code it's title 10 or title 32.
um so when mobilized under title 10 uh
Guardsmen are directed by the president
to report for active duty in an official
capacity where they are under the
command of the president United States
and the federal government will provide
budgetary funding title 10 allows the
president to federalize National Guard
units for the lawful purposes of
National Defense overseas trainings and
of enforcement of federal Authority
when mobilized under title 32 uh
Guardsmen remain under the command of
the governor who's the
commander-in-chief of his or her
respective State National Guard service
under title 32 was primarily State
active duty or was common referred to as
state call-up these missions commonly
are in response to Nash natural or
man-made disasters and Homeland defense
where the individual states will provide
the budgetary funding
so this bill continues compliance with
both of these codes uh where title 32
has to deal with disasters and Governor
command of the guard and title 10
authorizes the National Guard uh into
Federal service
um so the problem this bill solves is
that Congress hasn't formally declared
war since 1942
today the government uses the
authorization for use of military force
uh aumf of 2001 uh it's intended to deal
with those who committed the 9 11
attacks uh but as with many of these
government overreach measures only one
representative actually voted against
the thing it was Barbara Lee who stated
it's a blank check to the president to
attack anyone involved in December 11th
attacks anywhere in any country without
regard to our nation's long-term foreign
policy economic and National Security
interests without time limit and
granting these overly broad Powers the
Congress failed its responsibility to
understand the dimensions of its
declaration I could not support such a
grant of War making authority to the
president I believe it would put more
innocent lives at risk the president has
the Constitutional authority to protect
the nation from further attack and has
mobilized the Armed Forces to do just
that the Congress should have waited for
the facts to be presented and then acted
with Fuller knowledge of the
consequences of our action so that was
uh Barbara Lee on the amuf uh in her
ignored statements predicted the
situation we are now where the aumf has
been allowed to allow U.S to conduct
operations in Afghanistan Philippines
Georgia Yemen uh to Buji Kenya Ethiopia
Iraq Somalia and others so uh we're
arguing that the aumf is not legal
according to section one I mean article
one section 8 of The Constitution it's
well understood that Congress has the
power to declare war not the executive
branch and also that Congress cannot
simply delegate its authority to declare
war to the executive branch
and it's uh to to assert that the aumf
is legal according allowing the federal
government to conduct War over 20 20
years later where those members of
Congress aren't even in office anymore
um
you know and it's just like this blanket
declaration uh it's not really in what
what the Constitution was intended to do
uh the thing is you know war is the it's
the greatest thing the state does I mean
they dropped uh two atomic bombs you
know on civilian populations in the 40s
and that that kind of power can't just
be left up to just blanket declarations
uh so the fiscal note suggests that
which was already brought up that we're
going to lose Federal funding because of
this thing now the thing about losing
Federal funding is or being able to have
these uh agreements with bases and
whatever uh is is for it doesn't matter
if the thing's illegal right if if we
have an illegal National Guard the the
funding like the actual bill if you read
the text it says
you know on the fiscal note it says
something along the lines of you know
this would make us follow the
Constitution and then we'll lose the
funding it's like okay well so do we
have an illegal Army then is that is
that the fiscal note almost suggests
that the National Guard is legally
funded because we're not in compliance
with the United States Constitution
um but even with that uh so
title 32 with uh there's a section 108
Which authorized the forfeiture of funds
when a state fails to comply with the
requirements of title 32
um so the the bill doesn't affect our
compliance even with title 10 uh but
under title 32 it's not even under
question because title 32 is under
command of the governor it's intended
for disasters and Homeland defense so I
don't know where they're coming up with
this number because there's no reason
for us to lose Federal funding there's
no in compliance with any of these codes
um
and then additionally section 108
doesn't result in immediate immediate or
immediate forfeiture of funds instead
the president must first give the state
a time frame which to remedy the failure
to comply and even if a state did not
yield the president has discretion to
determine how much funding may or may
not be withdrawn
and then also it's not even politically
feasible for the federal government to
pull funding from National Guard troops
so if they were authorized to do it they
wouldn't I mean the National Guard is
extremely popular with the public people
are very concerned about you know
funding for the National Guard and if
the federal government just started
saying we're going to pull funding I
mean it No No One's Gonna No One's Gonna
fight that battle I mean it's just
completely politically unfeasible to
just pull funding from the from the
National Guard
um
so uh
all right and then just continue with my
testimony so the legislation is popular
with the new New Hampshire citizens uh I
talked to many members of my own
Community Republicans and Democrats it's
Universal I mean uh Americans in their
heart know from Civics their Civics
training that you know lawmaking is is
part of Congress and that Congress
declares the wars uh so when I when you
bring up this kind of thing to them they
say of course we should retain our
National Guard troops out of combat
unless there's a ejaculation of War I
mean it's it's like a no-brainer for uh
grandstaters
so uh I haven't talked to any regular
person that thinks that this is a bad
measure uh oh and in addition to that
there's lots of public organizations
that uh defend that support defend the
guard the ACLU of West Virginia supports
the defend the guard act as uh you know
they had the bill a bill similar Bill
brought to the West Virginia Congress
and they said um
so uh supports the defender guard is an
appropriate assertion of congress's sole
authority to wage war the conclusion of
the aclu's letter to the West Virginia
House Judiciary Committee States
the defender guard act seeks to use the
limited power of the state over the
National Guard to pressure the
Congressional executive branches of the
federal government to reverse the trend
of multiple long-term military
operations which any layperson would
understand to be War without a
congressional declaration of war as
required by Article 1 Section 8. it is
clear from multiple sources of law that
the power to declare war lies with
Congress
Congress has attempted to legislate much
of that Authority uh away both in Broad
feral code and through specific
authorizations uh the use of military
force it is not clear whether it is not
clear whether Congress can duly give
away Congressional Authority in such a
manner
so all we're asking for is that before
the country decides to send uh New
Hampshire National Guard troops into
combat to kill and be killed that first
the Congress does their Duty uh and
signs a declaration of war as they are
constitutionally required to
um so obviously I urge the committee to
make a OTP motion uh
recommendation for the house and that's
my testimony
thank you representative Senator say
your name again for the record
thank you and thank you for your service
uh questions for representative
thank you for your testimony your
thorough testimony we have about 10
cards or so so there's a lot of interest
in this so uh as you testify uh you know
please say what you would like to say if
if some points have already been uh made
that are part of your testimony then
that you don't need to reiterate what
has been said unless you feel a need to
all right next up uh represent Manning
do you uh
do you have any written uh testimony
you'd like to submit uh this is just my
scratch paper it's a mess okay so you
don't want to read this
question was about written testimony in
um
I will point out that our sessions are
on YouTube and which makes it a little
bit easier for our clerk knowing that uh
there's a a record out there and uh
before I go to represent Manny and I uh
previous speaker mentioned we haven't
declared war since 1942 which is true
the last time we declared war was in in
January of 1942 in the country we
declared war on was Bulgaria in case you
didn't know that all right Russian
Armenian um welcome thank you thank you
Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Tom minion I'm a representing
Hillsboro District uh Juan Pelham I'm a
Marine Corps infantry veteran that
enlisted in 2004 to hunt down those
responsible for 9 11. however I didn't
get a chance to do that like all service
members I went where I was told even
though I didn't completely understand
why you're going to hear counter
arguments today but take it from an
enlisted grunt that's been knocked onto
my ass into Iraqi dirt by a VB IED
there's nothing that convinced me to
continue sending our Guardsmen into
Harm's Way without going through the
correct process
my first deployment to Iraq start in
August 2005. one of the guys in my
platoon was from New Orleans and he
learned about Hurricane Katrina over a
satellite phone call back home
he was raised by his grandmother and he
was alone and she was alone during that
catastrophe we gave him our allotted sat
phone time to make calls to neighbors to
make sure she got out safely it wasn't
until years later that I found out that
the Louisiana National Guard was
deployed to Iraq right around the same
time we were the Department of Defense
sent active duty Marine Corps infantry
battalions to help with Katrina using
War fighters to fulfill the mission
objectives of search and rescue
Guardsmen the motto of the National
Guard is always ready always there but
the operation supporting
unconstitutional Wars prevents them from
fulfilling this Florida National
Guardsmen were training Ukrainian
soldiers instead of helping the
hurricane disaster relief fires in
Oregon were left to spread because their
guard were in Afghanistan
Kentucky Guardsmen were in Syria
protecting the interests of oil
companies instead of aiding their
neighbors back home when tornadoes
devastated communities
this committee was briefed by the
adjutant general last week where he said
over 300 of our New Hampshire Guardsmen
were deployed to the Middle East right
now imagine if we got smashed by a
nor'easter and needed those 300 here to
assist our families and Neighbors
they would not be there they were
instead off supporting an
unconstitutional undeclared war
another terrible consequence of these
unending Wars is the mental and
emotional toll on our service members
again as this committee was brief last
week New Hampshire is one of the states
with the highest suicide rate among
veterans
this is a serious problem that we in
this legislature can combat by passing
HB 229 Force Congress to do their
constitutional duty to risk the ire of
their constituents by voting for these
nonsense Wars that do nothing to protect
us at home before committing the lives
of our Guardsmen these men and women
signed up to defend us the least we can
do is vote OTP to show we are defending
them I'm happy to answer any of your
questions
thank you representative questions
for wrestlemanian
saying and I thank you for your
testimony representative thank you and
we will now go to uh
Kevin Grady Colonel Grady is still in
the house
welcome back
thank you Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen the committee again for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I
represent of a 25-year Air Force veteran
and I'm a 23-year resident of Hooksett
and I represent the state veterans
advisory committee
um we discussed this bill at our meeting
on January the 3rd and and we said it
sounds a lot like HB 1092 from the last
session and I was given permission at
that meeting to say that we don't
support this bill and I was also given
permission to contact uh representative
potusik as the bill sponsor and say that
we do not support this bill as a veteran
Community here in New Hampshire and and
give him the reasons why title 10 of U.S
law I'm going to let Colonel Perry he's
going to testify later talk to you about
title 10 and how that that really
applies here but it title 10 is is the
law and it's not it's not really
optional you know post Desert Storm
we we downsized the military quite a bit
and to be perfectly honest right now
Garden Reserve forces are not nice to
have forces for our government they're
they're must-have forces the tankers we
have sitting on the ramp over at peace
you know Governor sununu didn't write a
check for those okay we those are Air
Force assets and they're part of the air
bridge to to Europe and those things are
in operation all the time supporting
real world uh missions
um we particularly take exception in the
in the state veterans advisory committee
to congress not really doing their job
just because they haven't exercised
their article one authority to declare
war okay to give you a very brief
history lesson in August of 1964
we had a couple of North Vietnamese
Patrol boats that fired on a U.S Navy
ship in the Gulf of Tonkin and for their
time in trouble they were both sunk but
President Johnson went to the Congress
and said they are shooting at our boys
over here and the Congress said all
right we're going to pass the Gulf of
Tonkin Resolution and we're going to
give you essentially a blank check to do
whatever you want when the war was over
in 1973 the Congress rethought that idea
and said that was really not a very good
idea at all so they passed the War
Powers Act of 1973 which basically says
the president can go any place he needs
to or she needs to for 60 days
and use military force where that's
necessary after that 60-day period also
subject to 30 days bringing everybody
home you have to come and tell us what
you're doing or we're going to cut the
money off
this bill when I did some research on it
this bill was actually passed sent to
President Nixon he vetoed it it went
back to the Congress and they overrode
his veto and said we're in charge of
this stuff so we're gonna we're gonna go
ahead and do this if you'll remember in
your history why did President George
H.W bush go to the Congress and get an
authorization to use military force
before Desert Storm required to by the
War Powers Act same song second verse
for President George W bush for both
Afghanistan and Iraq
um there's a lot of extensive
coordination goes goes that goes around
when we send folks into combat zones or
when we just send people anywhere that
deploy that the governor's always kept
aware of all of those things and there's
very extensive coordination there
the truth of the matter is
this bill is not going to get what the
sponsors behind me want it to do if you
want to to prevent you know the idea
that you think that Congress isn't doing
their job then then we have four
perfectly good members of our
Congressional Delegation that can
introduce that legislation for you on a
federal level and see if we can change
title 10. as it is right now we're not
going to change title 10 of U.S law from
Concord all right you want to do that
it's going to have to be at the federal
level it's not going to be at the state
level at the state level I'll tell you
what they'll do what they'll do is
they'll say well
if you don't want to if you don't want
to play we're just going to take our
toys and go home that's the same thing
they threatened with the folks over at
Burlington when they had already spent
50 million dollars to build facilities
for the new F-35 over there and they had
a group of citizens that said you know
we think that's going to be too loud
we'd rather have you put something
quieter in here so we'll whip back
everything up and move it and shut the
Vermont guard down if you want to and
then they decided Well no okay maybe
we'll uh we'll bring the f-35s in which
by the way they don't take off in after
Burger most of the time anyway so it's
not that loud it's not louder than F-16
anyway that's really all I wanted to
tell you because I know Kurt there's a
lot of people that want to talk in
Colonel Perry is going to talk some
other things about title 10 and but we
do not support this legislation like we
did in support 1092 like we didn't
support
580 in the previous in the previous
three sessions there's been three
consecutive two two previous were itl
thank you Colonel Grady uh you're
representing the state veterans advisory
committee svac could you take a quick
moment and just uh tell us what that
organization is yes sir we are are
chartered by state RSA 115 colon 8 the
colon 8-8 to speak for the veteran
Community uh in New Hampshire we have uh
20 member organizations that are that
are in there and these are names that
should be familiar to you like the
association of the U.S army the uh the
disabled American veterans the Veterans
of Foreign Wars I did give the committee
a list of who the 20 voting members are
of our of our state veterans advisory
committee but we we and we give a report
once a year to uh to the legislature on
the bills that we followed and and our
our positions on those bills comes out
in October
questions for Colonel Grady
uh Colonel I have a quick question I
know we have a lot of folks who want to
testify but I you referenced uh
president H W bush in 1990 going to
Congress for the uh off Force
authorization which passed nearly my
circumstances at the time uh gave me
extreme interest in that vote uh my
understanding is the general uh
President Bush at that time said that
had in this past narrowly particularly
in the U.S Senate uh the authorization
for the use of force in 1990 Desert
Shield
the president reportedly said that had
congress not authorized that use of
force he was going to use Force anyway
do you recollect him saying that I I
don't recollect that I was on the wrong
side of the uh of the of the the world I
was in uh Okinawa and I was actually
sitting on Alert in South Korea when uh
when the actual fighting started on the
15th of January of uh 91 so I didn't I
did not follow that no sir okay I see
some heads nodding in the back uh
because that was my recollection and of
course it was a moot point it passed but
had it not passed that is something that
remains of concern to folks was that
President Bush said he was going to go
ahead anyway he's not here God Rest his
soul but uh thank you uh
Noah Blanchette is here
um they say that correctly
uh welcome to state federal and veterans
from antrum representing himself
morning Mr chairman good morning members
of the committee
um I don't have a whole ton to say I
just wanted to come today and give my
support for the bill I come from a Small
Town of Antrim New Hampshire I'm a
former National Guard member for six
years
um and I think what this bill's doing is
a good thing I don't believe that we
should be deploying the guard
to these combat scenarios without formal
declaration of war
I just think it's
I don't know I just think it's kind of a
difficult gray area
whereas we could um navigate that by
following uh
the things we have written in the
Constitution
that's that's all I have to say sir
thank you Mr blancheck questions
would you take any questions if there
are any
supposed to ask you that first
um I suppose so sir are there any
questions
thank you so much Mr Blanchette from
Windham
sir I'm sorry antrum Antrim New
Hampshire
thank you sir thank you
uh
yes representative there are some other
Representatives that would like to
testify uh that they said their their
rep their name was their title was on
the pink card
yes thank you as a courtesy custom often
is to try to allow reps an opportunity
to speak up front I see representative
Edwards is in the house representative
uh Edwards
thank you Mr chair
um I I won't I won't wear my hat out of
respect for the uh the body uh it's my
Afghanistan veteran hat uh with my
Combat Action Badge on it I served I'm
here today
um as a veteran which is why I'm not in
the normal suit and tie decorum uh I I
was a 33 and a 33 year four-month
veteran exactly one third of a century
a little over half of that was in the
garden the Reserve I retired as a
Lieutenant Colonel army guy after
volunteering for a deployment into
Afghanistan I did two mobilizations
after 9 11.
uh when you're in Afghanistan at night
you have cigars and fake beer to think
about things and so I spent a lot of
time thinking about the Constitution one
of the things I've I that I think is
important to remember and I think you'll
get this as a history
professional Mr chair is the reason that
we gave congress the right to or the
power to declare war in our constitution
it's because the scholars of the 1700s
had seen kings abuse the ability to
use conflicts with external parties as a
way to keeping the rabble from rousing
and
um and because leaders tend to know that
the most effective way to unign a a
population is to find a common enemy and
so leaders throughout history and into
the future will use that reality of
human behavior when needed to to Rally
people behind them by finding a common
enemy and so it was deemed important to
keep the executive from having that
unilateral power and put it back into
the hands of the people where it belongs
and so I'm I'm fully in support of the
concept and principles of this bill
because I I think we've had a poor
history of of compliance with that
important belief and to your earlier
point about President Bush saying he
would go forward even without the
Congressional
authorization I think that would have
been a fascinating Supreme Court case
you know and I think he would have lost
that because he would have directly
thumbed his nose at a very specific part
of our constitution so so what we have
done and what the Supreme Court has
recognized
is that rather than declaration of war
as long as the Congress was showing an
affirmative step towards authorizing the
military force and the Supreme Court has
ruled even a new appropriation
specifically to deploy the force and to
arm the force that that's sufficient and
so I I won't step on the Supreme Court
because I think they know it better than
I do and I and and maybe
starting on line 22 were the or Clause
is put in or has taken an official
action pursuant to Article 1 Section 8
Clause 15. you know that that may if if
I were a scholar a
supreme court scholar I I'm I could tell
you whether or not that was adequate to
ensure that some Congressional actionist
is needs to be taken and I don't think
it needs to be the formal declaration of
war that's not the way the Supreme Court
is interpreted but just some affirmative
action and
um
so I if if that is adequate I I don't
know that I would have a problem uh with
this bill
um and I I think the fiscal note as much
as I respect the people who put the
fiscal notes together in the process
used I I I think it's a hypothetical I
think it's definitely the worst case
scenario uh I think if New Hampshire
simply told Congress and the president
that we expect them to take an
affirmative action before sending our
guard into Harm's Way that that would be
perceived to be a reasonable position
and so I I would encourage you to think
about this in terms of history and
principles of our Constitution and not
not not let this money issue distracts
you from what I think is really the
important argument here
we we know we can't trust the federal
government we we know that when we
bombed Libya for over 60 days nobody
asked for a declaration of the War
Powers Act and I think that was a huge
sin against our constitution and even
our federal laws so so the the the the
the things that we have put in place
have continued to be flouted the two
Congressional authorizations to go into
the Middle East on uh
um enduring Freedom
um and the like uh have never
expired they could call up under those
same authorizations today and re ignite
a war in anywhere from uh you know Syria
to Iraq uh to to Libya apparently so
um it's way too broad it gives way too
much discretion to the president to
Rally the American people behind the
flag to to find a common enemy and take
us into war and we should recognize that
and resist that I believe
um so so if I were if I were better at
this if I knew what the Supreme Court
precedents were around interpreting
article on Section 8 Clause 15
Provisions uh I I could tell you if I
supported this outright or if it needed
an amendment but
um I I
if if this committee it yelled it I
could understand that if you amended it
I could understand that I just I just
want to say that there is a very
reasonable uh argument and conversation
that we should be having around this
because
um you know the power to send people
into combat is an awesome power and
we've put controls in place for a very
valid historical purpose so that that's
my testimony
thank you representative we'll take any
questions I I will are there any
questions uh representative Finney thank
you Mr chairman um you know thank you
for being here Jess um
my one question and I'm hoping I'm not
being redundant here
um we're we're talking to the Congress
about trying to limit the scope of their
powers back to the to our one of the
Constitution but this then
affected the executive
um from issuing an executive order that
would override Congress and that our
governor would would have to comply with
could we say you know could we still say
no at that point well okay so I uh
representative Finney I appreciate the
question and I'm going to disclaim my
answer I I I'm not an attorney I'm just
a Layman who's been reading
constitutional law for about 30 years
out of sort of uh interest
um and and and what I would say is that
if uh we had an instance where Congress
had explicitly had an opportunity to
take an affirmative action to to fund or
otherwise support an aggressive military
action and chose not to that if the
president were to issue an executive
order uh to to try to overcome that it
it's my belief that the current makeup
of the Supreme Court would likely uh
rule against the executive order because
it would be such an egregious and
obvious
refutation of the of the declared powers
of the Congress I think I want a
clarification on that because uh that
part is is more important in my opinion
because
um we have an executive branch who's
overtaking their power a little bit too
much and so I want to make sure that
we're checking that power as well as the
the the power of of Congress to make
these uh orders and I I I I I I think
the the process of having this
legislation considered is a good
educational opportunity for the
legislature and even if it were to pass
I think it's real effect and the real
world would be pretty negligible because
New Hampshire is is a small element of
our overall defense posture uh we might
make the national news and we might get
some other states to think about this
um you know the sanctuary movement for
illegal immigration started with a
single State you know you never know
when the power of a good idea might
catch fire but if we're kind of isolated
and taken this action I don't I don't
think it will have any practical real
world effect
other questions
Cena thank you representative Edwards
Lieutenant Colonel Edwards
representative Granger
supporting the bill
representative Edwards can we get a pink
card from you before you depart
oh okay
okay Carry On
what did you just
help
your name
sometimes oh okay it's not indicated my
handwriting is pretty bad
thank you representative speaking uh for
the measure
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Michael Granger I'm
representing Stratford District 2
Rochester Ward 5 Milton and Milton Mills
I'm a former National Guard infantryman
who deployed in sport of operation
enduring freedom in the year 2012 as
part of alpha company's second 108th
Infantry here in New Hampshire our
National Guard is an integral part of
our communities they serve with pride
distinction and courage rarely matched
in Washington only earlier this month
the National Guard operated mobile
Dentistry services in Manchester for
underserved youth on December 22nd staff
sergeant Dante Davis engaged in an act
of heroism by rescuing a young woman
stuck in an overturned SUV
on December 15th members of the New
Hampshire National Guard served in
providing thousands of donated
children's gifts to communities across
the state the list goes on from search
and rescue services to helping with
short-staffed hospitals the National
Guard citizen soldiers are an essential
part of operations in New Hampshire this
is just a recent selection only in the
last several months of all the valuable
Services provided by national Guardsmen
and these are all services that they
cannot provide if they are deployed for
combat on the opposite side of the
planet from the communities that rely on
them this legislation aims to fix that
by requiring Congress to provide an
actual declaration of war before
National Guardsmen are deployed into
combat
Congress has not bothered to actually
declare a war since 1942. despite this
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of soldiers have been sent to their
deaths on the opposite side of the
planet since the start of the global war
on terror National Guardsmen make up 45
percent of all deployed American
combatants and unfortunately make up 18
percent of the deaths so that's roughly
one in five dead soldiers that are done
overseas is from the National Guard
with their lives they unfortunately buy
New Hampshire absolutely nothing the
purpose of this bill is simple if New
Hampshire families are depart forever
with their beloved Sons and Daughters
then Congress should have to the courage
to actually declare war first if
Congress is too cowardly to declare a
war if the political shrapnel is too
difficult to face then Granite State
family should not be forced to send
their kids out to face real shrapnel
Everyone likes to read news articles
about mobile Dentistry units and heroic
staff sergeant saving people from cars
no one likes to read news stories about
our brave young people dying somewhere
they ought not be in the first place
this legislation ensures more of the
former and less of the latter you may
hear arguments today about how this
threatens Federal funding if you're
worried about that let the fiscal
committee figure it out I do not believe
that the federal legislators from this
state would ever authorize decreasing
the funding for the National Guard
especially since all they have to do to
utilize our National Guard is simply
declare war
you may hear arguments today about how
the Air National Guard is important for
refueling Jets this is not impacted by
this bill whatsoever this bill is about
combat refueling planes is not combat as
Daniel Webster put it it'll be a solemn
duty of the state governments to protect
their own authority over their own
militia and to interpose between their
citizens and arbitrary power I request
you vote ought to pass on this Bill
thank you for your time I am available
for questions
thank you representative questions
seeing on thank you again for your
testimony thank you and we will move to
uh Warren Perry uh as you were are there
any other legislator
legislators uh yes uh if you would come
on up and um do we have your card uh
president Garrett from Merrimack County
correct
indeed
thank you thank you
speaking for the bill go ahead yes
my name is Jason Gerhard representing
Northfield Franklin
and I want to address something I heard
has heard from the colonel I believe it
was
about the Gulf of Tonkin so this is from
the U.S naval Institute just the opening
paragraph to their article questions
about the Gulf of Tonkin incident have
persisted for more than 40 years but
once classified documents and tapes
released in the past several years
combined with previously uncovered facts
made clear that high government
officials and distorted facts and
deceive the American public about events
that led to the full U.S involvement in
the Vietnam War this is pretty open
information I don't know if anybody
actually looked into it but the Gulf of
Tonkin thing is kind of so using that as
a justification for setting National
Guard our neighbors overseas on some
specious Wars and the other thing I
wanted to address
was President Eisenhower's farewell
address just very briefly
this conjunction of an immense military
establishment and a large arms industry
is new in the American Experience the
total influence economic political even
spirituals felt in every city every
state house
every Office of the federal government
we recognize this imperative need for
this development we yet we must not fail
to comprehend his grave implications our
toil resources and livelihood are all
involved so is a very structure of our
society in the councils of government we
must guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military-industrial
complex
potential for this disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist
it goes on and it gets better but the
point being is there's obviously
the powers that ought not be are trying
to
threaten us and scare us into the idea
that we're going to lose everything we
have if we don't go along with
Washington's
dictates we have to stand up and why do
we why are the flags in the state house
when we walk through the Hall of flags
what are they there for
I mean people have died for the things
that we're doing right now debating and
actually looking at hey you know this is
the Constitution this is what they
actually swore an oath to uphold which
everyone in here did we already
acknowledge that the federal
government's not following it I mean we
can kind of you know what I mean I don't
understand the point of why this is even
Up For Debate they're not following the
law okay done bring our troops home we
can send them back you know we can get
our next flight back as soon as they
pass that resolution so I just I don't
know I don't see how this is that
complicated so thank you very much for
your time and uh
I'm done you take any questions if
they're already I doubt there will be
but I guess I will are there questions
from Gearhead
I'm trying to ask good questions you
know because this is an important issue
and I think that we need to stay engaged
in this is someone that that's also
served and I appreciate all you guys
being involved why do you think in your
purview that the federal government has
taken up guard units instead of active
duty units to to send to these places is
it because
they're trying to find a loophole in the
law or is it because it's cheaper for
them to send us
I think it's a little bit different I
think that people who join National
Guard so my twin brother enlisted at 17
and I actually was in the Army for two
and a half weeks long story but the
point being is I think National Guard
troops tend to join more for patriotic
reasons and during my time when people
were talking about why they enlisted it
seemed that the active the active Army
was more economic Reasons from what I've
seen and there was some just you know
some crazy people in there too but
um the National Guard people seem to be
more
it just seems to be more homebody type
like real
patriotic people and I think it's easier
to get them enlisted than active duty
does that I don't know if that makes any
sense but
is that I'm probably not wording it
right but it just so
yes
other questions
see none thank you representative uh and
now uh Warren Perry uh who opposes the
bill
but
good morning Mr chair for the record uh
Warren Perry Deputy Edge in general for
the New Hampshire's Department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
uh thanks for the opportunity to testify
today thanks for your service and thanks
to the service uh of all the people who
have testified here before me I like to
say before I give my formal remarks I'd
like to just kind of make comments on
testimony that you heard already today
first of all I take exception to the
fact that people don't join the regular
army for patriotic reasons I serve 28
years in a regular army I consider
myself a patriot
and I consider all the people who serve
in our Armed Forces Patriots whether
they're in the reserve components the
regular components wherever so uh
economic reasons may be a general
generating Factor but I'm sure that many
people join the National Guard for the
education benefits that we have here in
the states
so making that broad brush statement is
uh I just thought I'd address it on the
record
uh
second thing I'd like to say is I'm not
aware you heard testimony earlier about
the ACLU and other states and other
people supporting this this act I'm not
aware of any other state that's passed a
similar act I'd have to do a little more
research but as of last year when the
bill when the similar bill came before
the house there wasn't any and I don't
think any have passed this since then
the next thing I'd like to address is
the term instrumentality of War it is a
military Dragon piece but I would tell
you that the men and women who are
supporting the air Bridge across the
North Atlantic are instrumentalities of
War they're refueling aircraft that are
going to directly participate in actions
and combat actions or other actions
across the uh around the globe
and I think that this would impact our
ability to perform that mission without
a declaration of war not necessarily for
just pulling things in the Pacific but
certainly as we prepare to refuel and
station an aircraft around the world to
support that mission uh and extend the
uh the air capability of our planes in
the air certainly would have an impact
on that particular piece so to answer
your question there
next I'd like to talk a little bit about
status you heard about title 10 and
title 32 status and in fact that
testimony was correct I would just like
to clarify and be precise and say State
active duty is neither title 10 or title
32. both titled you know title 32 is a
state status federally funded
title 10 is a federal status federally
funded and state active duty is a state
status state funded so we can't lump
title 32 in state active duty together
and the example I'll give is the coveted
response was a title 32 status under the
control of the governor federally funded
so that's that's how that works so all
of the benefits of the National Guard
that you got in this state that we got
in this state about 700 of them over the
course of the time of the mobilization
for that time to support was federally
funded and you know and would have been
federally funded regardless of this bill
but I'm just saying that's the value
that they give I would also say that
those 700 Airmen and uh and army
Guardsmen Army and air Guardsmen that
were supporting that mission were doing
that while about 500 people were
deployed in support of global operations
so the fact that we we can do both is
what I'm telling you the guard can do
both
you know the backyard draft as some
people refer to it as we deploy folks is
not doesn't necessarily have the impact
that people think it has and I know all
of you benefited from the guard and the
guard support during the coveted
response while we were still persecuting
operations across the globe
I want to address the fiscal note a
little bit now we're in the fiscal note
does it say that we will lose 365
million dollars what it does say is that
it puts that risk Federal funding in
that amount
so uh you know that's what it is so the
national Guardsmen have a dual Mission
it's not just to support the state there
not just the militia for the state our
national Guardsmen and women swear two
Oaths they swear an oath to the
Constitution of United States of America
and the constitution of the State of New
Hampshire and both missions are equally
important the federal funding and all
the things associated with it are
associated with our ability to to
provide forces to support the federal
Mission so when we talk about that
fiscal note it doesn't say the money's
going to go away it says there's a
potential that it goes away and it's not
you know so I just a careful reading
we'll kind of put that in perspective
so uh
so what I will say is that current
statutes right and I I particularly
appreciate the testimony of uh Jess
Edwards who testified not as
representative Edwards but as Jess
Edwards and his constitutional uh
Scholars uh so before I make any other
four more marks I would just like to
cite two cases there were two cases in
the Supreme Court one in 1820 Houston
versus more
and one in 1827 and I think it was a
habit right here bear with me
Martin versus Mott in both of those
cases the question of whether or not the
president had the authority to activate
the militia was the question the
background of those two cases were the
president ordered people to militia to
to serve and uh soldiers disobeyed that
order and were punished for disobeying
the order of the president as in the
oath we swear obey the orders of the
president of the United States
uh and the orders of the officers have
pointed over you in both cases
uh based on an act that was passed in
the Supreme Court upheld Congress has
exercised its Authority by authorizing
the president to call forth the militia
in case is mentioned in the Constitution
so that was Houston versus Moore 1820
and in mott Martin versus Mott the act
of 1795 provided that whenever the
United States shall be invaded or be an
eminent danger of Invasion From Any
foreign Nation or Indian tribe it shall
be lawful for the president of the
United States to call forth such number
of the militia of the states most
convenient to the place of danger or
scene of action as he may judge
necessary to repel an invasion and I
would say that based on the
authorization authorization of use of
force that cited in my written testimony
that I think based on that the Supreme
Court this today would likely
stop have Starry decisions right they
would let those decisions stand based on
the precedent that was going on so as we
as we talk about this and we talk about
the constitutionality of the president
ordering the militia you know one of the
things we need to look at is whether or
not the con that U.S Congress is going
to rescind The Authority they have
delegated to the president in the
authorization of a force and I think
that that may be what's at issue here is
that the president has been delegated
that Authority and maybe Congress needs
to do something about that if they deem
necessary
so uh
right now what the department hangs its
hat on is title 10 United States code
section 12 301
and in summary in my written testimony
it says the consent of the governor is
described in sections B and D this is so
uh bowlegs F in that in that citation
this uh the governor as in those
instances described in B and D above may
not be when held in whole or in part
with regard to active duty outside the
United States its territories its
possessions because of Any objection to
the location purpose or type uh or
schedule of that active duty so title 10
is clear right
so so we're going to go back and kind of
look at the balance of powers right
Congress has been delegated powers in
the Constitution they delegate those Co
those powers to the president United
States and the authorization use force
act or the other Act of 17 uh
95 the Supreme Court's ruled on it seems
like what I was taught in my Civics
classes we kind of worked it all out
right the balance of powers kind of they
they they work so if there's a violation
of the Constitution there the Supreme
Court hasn't found it seems like
Congress has delegated it and the
president has executed it and what we
need to change is whether or not
Congress is going to
change this authorization
you know and as as uh Jess Edwards has
stated this bill's not going to have any
impact on that because the governor is
not going to have the power to withdraw
his consent based on title 10.
so that's kind of where where we sit I
will tell you that the fiscal impact
that the federal government brings to
the state of New Hampshire is
significant right those airplanes cost a
lot of money particularly the new ones
that they have there all of the trucks
that we used are in covet they don't
belong to the state of New Hampshire
they belong to the federal government
and the federal government buys their
gas it buys all the money it takes to
train them and it spends all the money
it takes to man them right so why would
we put that at risk because they can do
like I said earlier both they can
support the state and obey the orders of
the president United States uh together
I am uh I am a 28-year veteran of the
United States Army I did deploy both to
Desert Storm and to operation Iraqi
freedom I lost men in combat like many
of the men behind me did
and nobody wants to fight Wars less than
us
but I don't see I can't see you know
based on my patriotism not following the
orders of the president and I don't see
that they're illegal based on the
citations that I've I've given you in
the comments that I've made so I'm happy
to answer any questions I I urge the
committee to to to
vote this inexperience to legislate as
written so if it's amended certainly
come back and talk to you again about it
and consider the Amendments but that's
my testimony sorry I drug on a little
long hopefully I made sense well I'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you thank you Mr Perry questions
yes Mr chairman uh representative gagne
thank you Colonel for taking my question
this is like an aside question aside
from the money potential losses
uh we had orientation last week where we
you came and and others presented that
the Enlistment
was down
uh could it be my opinion I'm asking for
yours could it be because of all the
many freaking deployments that are being
made
I I would tell you that everybody in the
Army and the Navy and the Marine Corps
and the Air Force and the space force
and the Coast Guard they're tired
I can tell you that right now and I
think that's having an absolute impact
on our ability to recruit our forces
there are many in my opinion right so in
my opinion uh
I think what believe it or not and some
people don't necessarily like to hear
this and it was mentioned a little bit
earlier some people joined the army
because for economic reasons
a lot of times the economy drives the
drives the the
enlistment pieces and it's been pretty
good
but the propensity to enlist is down and
our soldiers and Airmen are tired and I
would tell you it's not only having an
impact on our ability to recruit but
it's also having an impact on our
ability to retain
ER that's a short and sweet answer to
your question
now the questions they're tired
thank you thank you Mr Perry okay we
have seven more cards here all seven are
in favor of the bill supporting the bill
looking forward to hearing from all of
you have taken time to be here I'll just
point out that if certain points that
you may have
uh ready to state if they've been stated
we'd really be looking for some some New
Perspectives and we'll go right now to
zephan Wood
from Pembroke
for the bill
thank you all for your time and
attention my name is zephan I'm a
concerned citizen of Pembroke who wishes
to have a return to the Constitution and
a more peaceful United States world
Article 1 Section 8 of the U.S
Constitution vests in the Congress the
exclusive power to declare war and by
abdicating the War Powers to the
Executive Branch the United States
Congress has failed to follow the United
States Constitution and the intent of
the founders additionally article 25 of
the New Hampshire Constitution states
that standing armies are dangerous to
Liberty and ought not be raised or kept
up without the consent of the
legislature
the US government has engaged in Endless
Warfare that sees no end in sight
countless service men and women have
died in conflicts that have no specific
goal or objective and without
Congressional approval as the
Constitution mandates
New Hampshire can serve as a check
against this gross abuse of power by
retaining ownership of its National
Guard only reserving them for foreign
deployment if there isn't officially
declared war by Congress so Congress can
be held accountable to the American
people if they do not approve of the
results
as it stands there are huge
bureaucracies in the executive branch
that perpetuate War for profit at the
expense of those that put their lives on
the line believing that they are
defending this country in a manner that
is constitutionally permissible
this is not what the founding fathers
intended and if Congress does not want
to change the Constitution then defend
the guard will restore a bit of the
founding Vision incentivizing the
re-establishment of the process of War
rather than an endless cycle perpetuated
by an unaccountable uncontrollable
viratic executive branch
war is a very serious matter and
deployment should only take place in
circumstances of self-defense defend the
guard is a way of ensuring that this is
the case at least on a state level
it's important to note that war has not
officially been declared by Congress
since World War II as previously
mentioned this provides a check against
the Executive Branch from continuing to
perpetuate endless Wars and having the
U.S military serve as a global police
force
if Congress wants this continued they
need to pass a constitutional amendment
uh to make it so not simply pass the War
Powers Act or any other legislation
that that has the same level of strength
as the US Constitution as we are a
nation of laws that must adhere to our
constitutional framework
Congress has failed to act and will
continue to fail to act on this
constitutional mandate as many of them
are personally benefited to see the war
machine continue even if it negatively
affects New Hampshire and American
families
having a Perpetual state of War through
the constant deployment of armed forces
including the National Guard actually
weakens National Security in my opinion
by extending resources that
um when they are not needed and creating
enemies out of allies through
unnecessary military intervention
I want my future children and
grandchildren to live in a world where
Nation shall not lift up the sword
against Nation neither shall they learn
War anymore
and I believe that defend the guard is a
great first step in ensuring this vision
therefore I encourage the committee to
make an OTP recommendation on HB 229 and
I thank you for your time and I'm open
to questions
thank you Devin questions
thank you again for your testimony for
showing up here appreciate that and
Derek Pro
from Jerry representing himself in
supporting the bill
I actually have a handout
thank you committee for giving me the
opportunity to speak on HB 229 defend
the guard my name is Derek pru I'm from
Derry New Hampshire I'm a former
Sergeant in the New Hampshire Army
National Guard served six years and I
support this bill
now uh I'm going to start with a quote
for from President James Madison the
Constitution supposes what the history
of all governments demonstrates that the
executive is the branch of power most
interested in war and prone to it it is
accordingly with studied care vested the
question of war in the legislature
now I joined out of a sense of duty to
protect uh foremost my state which is
why I enlisted in the National Guard I
wanted to be sure that I was there for
any kind of uh State emergency whether
it be snow storms or flooding anything
like that and then of course to uphold
and defend the Constitution United
States which I have my Constitution
right here open to Article 1 Section 8
which clearly states that Congress has
the authority to declare war Grant
letters of Mark and reprisal make rules
concerned and captures on land and water
so
um knowing this and uh while I was doing
overseas training mission in Hungary uh
I was part of a high Mars unit Third
Battalion one third of the 197th field
artillery Bravo battery
um in my high Mars waiting on a fire
mission uh kind of just
looking through news see what's going on
in the world at the time and I came
across what was called the Pentagon
papers which was released by The
Intercept and in the Pentagon papers it
was found that ninety percent of drone
strikes in the Middle East was not on
the intended target
90 and that mostly came from The
Whistleblower Airman Daniel Hale and so
learning that information uh and being
field artillery where a lot of our uh
intel was probably a lot of the same
Intel that these drone Pilots were
getting uh that really concerned me uh
in terms of my my service and so I
started really looking into uh the
purpose of these wars in the Middle East
and what was going on uh the background
and what I discovered was that these
wars were unconstitutional they were
never declared like was previously
stated the last declaration of war was
World War II
and the Constitution is very clear about
what happens with war and Congress
should be the ones to declare war
and then uh you know reading about
authorization for the use of military
force
um it's not a war declaration it is uh
like it's been previously stated a blank
check it doesn't mention anything about
uh Geographic or uh budgetary or time
restraints or anything like that
um and you can clearly see that we've
been intermittently involved in places
like Somalia since 1993 that's almost 30
years of military engagement and in
other places across the world
and so the real question is is can
Congress legislate away their
constitutional Authority
um some might say yes my assertion is
that no they can't do that they must
abide by the supreme law of the land
which is the United States Constitution
section one uh article one section 8
. I just wanted to address some things
uh Mr Perry mentioned uh repel invasions
this bill itself says that the president
does have the authority to repel
invasions this bill doesn't try to
prevent that another thing is in title
10 section 12 301 subsection F which
mentions the government the governor
withholding their consent cannot
withhold their consent for location
purpose type or schedule of active duty
we're not asking that the governor do
this we're asking if the governor
withhold this consent on the basis that
Congress is not following the supreme
law of the land we're not objecting to
location purpose type or schedule of
active
um I also have right here
um I
didn't print enough of these copies but
when this bill was introduced in Kansas
the uh Kansas Division of budget uh
their fiscal note was the adjutant
General's Department states that the
enactment of SB 370 that was their
version of this bill would not have a
fiscal effect so again other states are
saying that this is not going to have
any effect any any
budgetary
reprisals is purely speculation and then
we can also look at in New Hampshire
with our you know not having a seat belt
law not re-numbering our exits uh not
having motorcycle helmets we're already
in that chicken fight with the
government over Federal funding of
Highway budget which we've won we kind
of call their Bluff they're not
withholding any funds from from those
purposes
and
um I'm just going to repeat this it is
the solemn duty of the state government
to protect their own authority over
their own militia and to interpose
between their citizens and arbitrary
power that is our very own Daniel
Webster
uh I'm open to any questions
from the committee
I would also like to say that training
mission in Hungary this bill would not
affect that training Mission overseas
training is not affected by The Spill
thank you for that and thank you for
your well-organized testimony appreciate
the written testimony the clerk does
especially as well
okay I I also uh emailed um sorry it's
our go on I also emailed the uh uh
American Legion Post uh 39 in Maine who
endorsed this bill and then also the
West Virginia ACLU who was also endorsed
the spell I emailed that to all members
of the committee
thank you for that
okay we still have five cards here uh
all sporting the bill will go quickly
right now to Joshua Holmes if he is in
the house and he is
Joshua was from Manchester and as I said
supporting the bill
hello thank you all for your service to
our state and its institutions
I was born and raised in Manchester I
enlisted in the Army when I was 18. I
fought in Iraq when I was 19 and again
when I was 21.
I have watched American soldiers bleed
to death while our Medics worked on them
I have been a first responder to a mass
casualty suicide bombing at an Iraqi
police station
I have personally been in a vehicle that
was hit by a suicide Car Bomb and was
saved by the grace of God and heavy
armor
if we are going to ask our young men and
women to give their lives in service of
our constitution we have to follow it or
else you should drop the pretense
thank you for your time I'd be happy to
answer any questions
Sheena thank you for your service and
thank you for taking the time to come up
here
with you with those remarks which we
appreciate
okay
moving along to eloquy Leone if I'm
saying that correctly is alacare
supporting the bill he's coming here
from dairy and he'll make sure that for
the record we he says his name correctly
for us and for our
audience on the world wide web Alec
Leone sir yes that was correct
um
so I'm here today in support of this
bill uh as a former member of the New
Hampshire National Guard
um
the
the military power of the United States
is extremely
large and Powerful it is uh almost
without match
and I feel the ways it's been used over
the past decades
um have been extremely irresponsible and
as previously previously stated
questionably constitutional at best
um
while
the units from the New Hampshire
National Guard might not make up a
massive
portion of that might and power
um
I believe it's our duty at least to stop
enabling this uh
irresponsible Behavior where we can
even if that's just for the sake of our
neighbors and friends and family here
that's all I have to say thank you
thank you
would you take any questions if there
are any
any questions from the committee
and saying none at Alec thank you as
well for taking the time to be here
thank you
Richard kind from Hudson is here Richard
welcome to state federal and Veterans
which as I said is from Hudson and is
supporting me measure
thank you for the opportunity my name is
Richard Khan from Hudson New Hampshire
I come from a large well not a large
family a lot of military in my family my
father
still alive was Navy U.S Navy and World
War II
both my in-laws were Navy or well one of
them was Navy one was in the Army Air
Corps in World War II
and my wife retired from the Manchester
VA Hospital
after 17 years of service
and I support this bill because I
support what they had fought for
and the Constitution
and with that I'll take any questions
seeing on Richard I'd like to on the
behalf of the committee ask you to pass
on to your dad the World War II veteran
uh Earth thanks and and
acknowledgment for his service as well
as yours and everything I will do that
thank you
and thank you
will Hopkins is Will here he is
will is from Belmont correct
and is uh for the bill
hi my name is Will Hopkins um like so
many who spoke before me uh served in
the New Hampshire National Guard in Iraq
in 2004 and 2005. uh it was award a
combat infantryman's badge to Army
commendations one for Valor
um and I now uh professionally what I
what I've done for the last 14 is lead
the state's largest peace Group New
Hampshire peace action not a registered
lobbyist with New Hampshire peace action
so that's just uh I'm here as well but
um
would I I want to Echo what uh
representative Manion said
um also some um I've forgotten your name
Zephyr
um spoke very eloquently to how I feel
about this and I I wanted to add a few
things that I don't think are in the in
the conversation
um one is is that
um
when we talk about constitutionality
we're talking about who has the power to
declare Wars
um we also have article six the U.S
Constitution which
um which which says we have to follow
International treaties and included in
ratified uh International treaties is
the UN Charter
um which which uh is maybe the reason
why we haven't engaged uh in in
declaring Wars
um because it's very clear that it's
illegal to attack another country to put
your troops in another country under
that Charter and under article 6 of our
own Constitution
um and so I when we talk about what
we're you know what what missions are uh
being executed the US is supporting
things like the the war in Yemen the
saudi-led offensive there uh over a
hundred thousand people per year over
the last uh five or six years have died
of starvation and an engineered cholera
epidemic by the Saudi government that's
the kind of thing that sometimes we're
doing we spend 858 billion that's our
current national defense authorization
act 858 billion with a B that's more
than six times that of China more than
10 times that of Russia we have troops
in over 700 countries around the world
most of those on bases but we have uh
kinetic operations and over a dozen
countries
um and that uh isn't the it's it's not
um no and I want to go to a conversation
that I had with Colin Powell's Chief of
Staff Lawrence Wilkerson
um and Larry spent the night at my house
while he was in New Hampshire talking
about the revolving door and and the
reality that military keynesianism this
this reality that we've had penned on
jobs and politicians to defend depend
especially at the federal level on
contributions from Pentagon contractors
and that growth of the military sector
of manufacturing is a is something that
our economic system continues to grow
increasingly dependent on this bill
um you know I'm not a constitutional
scholar and I don't know what the
Constitutional law is what I know is is
what's right and wrong and that any
roadblocks we can put in to the
executive to uh closening our ties with
the Saudis when it comes to the Warren
blockade there to bombing and killing in
countries like Iraq and Syria and
Afghanistan where I engaged in combat in
Iraq multiple times
anything we can do to keep New Hampshire
soldiers from having to do that I hope
that you have the courage to do it you
know whether or not this bill can do
what it wants to do whether or not the
federal government pushes back and finds
a way to deploy our troops anyway
putting a small roadblock in and saying
hey maybe maybe we shouldn't be engaged
in combat in 13 countries is an act of
Courage that you who are I mean when it
comes to legislatures when it comes to
elected officials New Hampshire has the
people who are most tied into their
constituents and and who are most able
to do what's morally right because
they're not dependent on those big
contributions from Raytheon and Bae and
General Dynamics and I hope you guys
have the courage to do the right thing
and vote ought to pass and I'm happy to
take questions
thank you will questions for will
Hopkins down here from Belmont
Cena thank you for taking the time to
come down here on this uh on this snowy
day our final pink card on this measure
is uh in favor of the bill from Gabe
Holden is Gabe here
Gabe welcome
so uh I've been poor my entire life and
I don't represent them but I can tell
you what that perspective is like and
the reason that matters is because
it is disproportionately the poor that
joined the services
and
when they join the National Guard
they make an agreement with you
that they will guard the nation that
means two things that means that one
they will not do things other than guard
the nation they will not be the toy
soldiers of political Elites in
Washington
and number two that they will guard the
nation when it needs to be guarded I
mean I think we all know that Warfare
has changed and sure sometimes there is
a nation that is a threat to this one
and in those cases it's not hard to
declare war
and when that's war is declared that is
when that guard needs to be there
but there are other threats it is not
always a nation that we go
to defend ourselves from
and yeah they are authorized the the
Supreme Court authorized the president
to uh
to repel that means to drive back to
drive them out of this country you don't
repel an invasion from going to their
home
so
when
we make those choices and and yes a lot
of the the economic choice is the
education that you receive because it is
one of the most effective ways to get
yourself out of the bottom bracket
but you made an agreement with them
and I'm asking that you keep that
agreement
and I'd like to point out that as far as
I can tell everyone who opposes this are
the people who
benefit financially
from the blood of our citizens
and I'd like to end my statement with a
quote from one of the greatest
heroes of American History Major General
Smedley Butler
war is a racket
its profits are reckoned in dollars and
the losses in lives
thank you
questions or
comments for the speaker
not seeing any thank you
for taking the time to come down here
okay that was our final speaker on this
measure
and I will declare an end to that
particular session next up on our docket
is HB 269 now we are a little bit over
um
so before we get started on this I'm
looking for the prime sponsor
representative Porcelli
is where okay uh so before we get
started with the representative
introduce the bill I want to and I do
not know uh what type of uh the numbers
of potential testimony that will be here
I want to alert everyone and also the uh
this morning we have HB 330.
which was slated for this morning and
that was to be introduced
by represent Maguire and I don't see
representative McGuire uh represent well
are you here for represent McGuire
no I just wanted uh she's been here for
a while she understood sometimes we have
yes if if you could text her that we
will be a a while
so I do not know how many uh folks what
are we looking at for cards here okay
we're looking at three cards okay uh I
was going to alert folks that we what we
need to recess briefly at noontime there
is a uh informational luncheon that has
been set up with regard to some other
measures coming before us so we will
take some sort of a brief recess during
the noon hour uh not sure exactly when
that will be but that will happen FYI so
all that said
uh representative Porcelli welcome
to get my glasses out
good morning everyone and thank you for
allowing me to speak on this topic I am
representative Susan Porcelli Rockingham
District 19 from Hampton Falls in
Kensington
I am here today to present HB 269 and
act relative to limiting The Authority
of New Hampshire delegates to
policy-making conventions
this bill is also known as the faithful
delegate law is common sense legislation
to propose controls guidelines and guard
rails to limit The Authority of New
Hampshire delegates to any Interstate or
Interstate policy-making convention the
purpose of this bill is to ensure that
the New Hampshire legislature defines
the scope and sets limitations on the
role and authority of delegates
representing the sovereignty of New
Hampshire
a little bit of history about this bill
a previous version of this bill HB 148
passed both the House and Senate in
2015. unfortunately Governor Hassan
vetoed this bill because she said it was
not required at the time
also in 2022 HB 1170 passed the house
but was tabled in the Senate so the text
of this bill is the same as 1170.
and then as a an additional note in 2020
there was a Supreme Court decision
chiafalo versus Washington and the U.S
Supreme Court ruled in a 9-0 decision
that state legislatures maintained
control over their appointed delegates
this bill has three main components to
ensure the limitations of this Authority
is followed number one it establishes a
procedure for the selection of delegates
number two it limits the authority of
delegates to only those granted by the
New Hampshire legislature and number
three it creates a procedure for
recalling and replacing delegates who
act outside the scope and the authority
granted to them by the New Hampshire
legislature
the bill seeks to protect the
sovereignty of New Hampshire by defining
specific processes and procedures
the bill adds definitions such as
delegate
Interstate convention and permitted
scope
a delegate is defined as a person from
the state of New Hampshire selected by
the legislature to represent the people
in the state of New Hampshire at any
Interstate convention
an interstate convention means a
multi-state gathering for the purpose of
coordinating or proposing new written
policy or amendments to existing rules
or laws an example of an interstate
convention is the uniform law commission
that was established in 1892
to create uniform commercial laws ISO
New England
is an important Interstate convention
that reviews electric policy for New
Hampshire and the surrounding states
another example is commonly known as
Article 5 Convention of states
bill hcr1 on the resolution to apply for
a Convention of States under Article 5
of the U.S Constitution has been
introduced in the public hearing is on
Friday January 27th in front of this
committee
permitted scope outlines and defines the
specific topics that can be addressed by
these conventions as directed by the New
Hampshire legislature
detailed processes and procedures for
the selection of delegates are also
described in this bill
the New Hampshire General Court selects
delegates as outlined four delegates
selected by the house and three
delegates selected by the Senate the
process to select alternate delegates is
also documented
under this bill the authority of
delegates is clearly and precisely
detailed
delegates to an interstate convention
shall not have the authority to allow or
support any unauthorized amendment in
addition any vote taken by a delegate in
violation of this Authority shall be
disqualified and reported to the
Secretary of State
the Secretary of State shall take
immediate action to revoke the
credential of the delegate in question
and appoint an alternate
every delegate from New Hampshire to an
interstate convention shall be required
to take an oath affirming these
limitations on Authority
the secretary of state is required to
certify the selection of the New
Hampshire delegates as previously
discussed
and the secretary of state is
responsible for enforcing these policies
a few fiscal notes delegates are paid a
hundred dollars daily and reimbursed for
their actual expenses submitted the
daily payment could be approximately
257 per delegate in addition to
Transportation costs
and note that these Interstate
conventions have been limited over the
past two years and these expense
anticipated expenditures are in are
questionable at this time
in conclusion I urge the passage of this
bill to provide common sense legislation
to propose controls guidelines and guard
rails to select delegates limit The
Authority of New Hampshire delegates to
any Interstate policy-making convention
and provide a procedure for recalling
and replacing delegates that act outside
the scope of the authority granted by
the New Hampshire legislature
thank you and I will take questions
thank you Rose Jeff I do have a quick
question
um up front here the word interest
Interstate you used many times on line
four the title uh under chapter 20-c is
Authority of New Hampshire delegates to
Interstate conventions now in line 12
below that it refers to uh representing
the people in state of New Hampshire at
any Interstate slash interest state
so my question or concern here is given
that the word intra state is part of
this measure uh in your speaking it
sounds like to Interstate I'm I'm
concerned and I think others may be
concerned about this applying to
intrastate could you speak to that yes
it the same policies procedures would
apply to intrastate conventions but most
of the examples that we know occur
Interstate but yes that is part of the
bill
thank you for that questions for the
prime sponsor uh representative massimoa
thank you Mr chairman
in question
if any other states who have already
signed on for an article 5 convention
application have these same prevent uh
provisions and procedures in place or
are they different from what's presented
here
yes I believe they do however there are
some expert experts that will testify
specifically related to your question
thank you
other questions representative Charlotte
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um we talked a lot about Article 5
conventions but this bill actually goes
much further than a simple Article 5
convention you mentioned for example ISO
New England would become under the
regulation of the legislature as well as
interstate as the chair mentioned and I
suppose that could be a meeting of uh
registered Deeds from the 10th County
could be determined to be an interstate
meeting does the legislature really want
that product power
over the function of other
people in other groups
yes I'm sure that there needs to be a
threshold as to what specifically the
inter or Interstate convention topics
and
criticality would be to
be part of this bill so we could
certainly clarify that if it needs to be
thank you but it's not meant to be a
administrative burden
thank you representative Sherlock other
questions
uh representative
penalties of these imposed when the oath
was taken to just uh concentrate on what
the convention was convened for have you
any ideas as to what those penalties
might be
removal from the there would be the
delegate would be removed there and this
bill there are no financial implications
other questions
represent Finney thank you Mr chairman
uh has also a co-sponsor of this I I
wanted to
um maybe clarify for the rest of the
committee that that this bill
um that you could speak to that point of
water
is the member testifying or asking a
question yes as a co-sponsor there are
some limitations representative as to
what what you can say here uh so the
intent of your comment is I am asking a
question uh our rules rather preclude
co-sponsors from test uh questioning
sponsors uh of the bill that you're
co-sponsoring
uh so I would ask you to hold hold off
on that
uh other questions from from
non-sponsors
and saying that thank you representative
I have copies and I if it's okay I will
distribute them that would be
appreciated
uh looking at the clock
um representative Wallace is is a
courtesy to the sponsor of the next bill
if you could alert her that we will
looks like we'll take that up to be fair
uh at at one
thirteen third
thank you representative as a courtesy
at 1300 hours okay next up
uh former Senator James rubin's
um honorable Jim Reubens uh still of
Aetna
thank you
so I won't thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee for
hearing this testimony and considering
this bill
so I'm not going to repeat what I have
provided here in written form it's a on
the technical side
but but behind this bill I find because
I've been on the phone probably for
three and a half weeks over the past
three and a half weeks talking to
Republicans about this General topic of
the article 5 conventions uh authorized
in the U.S Constitution
and and behind that discussion is
whether delegates can be trusted to do
the work uh commissioned by the New
Hampshire legislature so this bill is
important
but but but the underlying
uh Pro Con on this bill seems to be
melded together with whether one
supports the power in the Constitution
under Article Five so I'll address that
by asking you sort of a rhetorical
question to myself members of the
committee and to the public
which is to what extent do you think
Congress is doing a good job dealing
with major structural issues and I'll
just two examples national debt and
campaign money so I know that both of
these issues animate the public uh the
public at large bipartisan super
majorities of the public support an
amendment to the U.S Constitution to
deal with the debt problem and to deal
with the campaign money problem across
the Spectrum so my question to myself
members of the committee to the public
do you think Congress is doing the job
of of tackling these issues and the
answer is clearly no there's not a
single person that I've talked with in
three weeks and my 10 years of working
on amending the Constitution in a
variety of capacities uh that answers
the question favorably we're very
frustrated with Congress so this bill
creates support it creates a sense of of
trust in the process laid out by the
framers of our United States
Constitution which which told us As
Americans that should Congress fail to
deal with major structural issues that
require amendments to the Constitution
should Congress fail for whatever reason
corruption or irresponsiveness
anticipated by the framers that the
states would have the power to step in
uh under a a procedure if two-thirds of
the States agree on any particular
subject uh to to appoint delegates and
the delegates are bound by the what's
called an application by the states our
state has a live application dating from
asking for a convention for opposing
amendments limited to the subject of
debt or budget balancing and so
questions come up to what extent are
these delegates under the control of the
New Hampshire legislature I'd argue that
based upon on case law and I've cited a
particular case here and decided
unanimously by our Supreme Court in the
year 2020 that the legislature's
application passed by this legislature
binds the delegates appointed by the
state of New Hampshire and by you folks
here in the room this legislature to do
the work contained in that application
which is limited to the subject of of
budget balancing and debt restraint
so that power in the hands you folks at
the legislature already exists Supreme
Court is unanimously identified and
confirmed that that exists but this bill
creates one extra layer of protection
and and and a sense of the safety of
this process This concerns about the
safety of the states stepping in where
Congress has utterly failed America to
deal with substantial significant issues
structural issues Congress has failed we
all agree on that at least I think so
this provides one extra layer of
protection of safety of security so that
you know you folks here in the
legislature who are commissioned to
appoint these delegates that I as a
member of the public I can trust you to
do a good job of appointing delegates
who will do the job that you've
commissioned them to do so for that
reason I strongly support this bill and
of course you can hear that my focus is
on the Article 5 convention process
that's that's where the main concerns
are registered uh and so I'll I'll just
conclude my testimony there except to
say I just recite my background I'm a
former state senator representing
District five which is Hanover New
London uh Lebanon area of New Hampshire
at the time I I was a former chair of
the New Hampshire GOP uh platform
committee I'm now a vice chair of the
Grafton County uh Republican Hanover
Lebanon area and I'm active have been
active very active in the amending
movement uh since uh since running for
the United States Senate and beginning
in 2013
uh I'm a member of a national Steering
group that works on dealing with Article
5 questions there are various groups
working on that I'm a board member of
American promise which is the nation's
leading organization seeking a
congressionally drafted Amendment
relative to campaign money reform I'm a
volunteer for Wolf Pack you'll hear from
someone from wolf pack a little bit
later
and I'm a volunteer backing the
convention of States application that
you'll hear uh next week
and I'm also a backer of hcr4 that
you'll hear sometime this afternoon so
I'm in favor of the process of the
states leading the process of resolving
major unresolved National issues and I
would hope that all members of this
committee would would find support for
this bill again in order to empower
create confidence create trust in this
process laid out by our framers of our
constitution to deal with major
structural problems that Congress is
ducking your head on and that super
majorities of the public across the
political Spectrum back so I thank you
for your time and questions welcomed
thank you Senator I have a question
um with regard to this measure which
spells out a process a structure for
delegate selection for an interstate
convention uh
what is in place now
um this is new language uh if if there
were a say a different measure move
forward for an article five or whatever
some sort of Interstate uh convention
um without this what do we have now that
would cover this uh situation
deeply embedded a gentleman here will
answer that type of thing but deeply
embedded in the materials in the links
to the links in this thing I've handed
out here is a citation of a interesting
uh summary of a book that was written
regarding uh the uh the amendment that
was passed uh to the 21st amendment that
repealed prohibition of alcohol and New
Hampshire appointed delegates we
appointed I think it was 10 delegates at
the time we appointed and each state in
in the process of the state delegation
uh empowered by Congress to ratify that
21st Amendment each state had its own
process so New Hampshire could the New
Hampshire legislature could choose its
own process and is empowered to do so so
if this bill were not to pass you
already have that power in the
legislature to determine how the
delegates would be appointed and that's
flexible according to what you see this
bill
and again this is a this is a Belton
suspenders approach to increasing
confidence in the power of the states to
resolve issues that Congress is ducking
and that will never Congress is in my
opinion bought and paid for if that's
just my opinion and that's why the
states are allowed to step in so this
this creates a known identified
predetermined structure by which
delegates could be appointed Etc and and
controlled although I'd argue again that
you already have these Powers you
already have total control over the
behavior of these delegates should this
bill not pass but this again I advocate
passage of this bill to increase
confidence increase Trust
that thank you Senator other questions
from the committee
see none thank you thank you Senator uh
representative Bernardi is
in the house and in the committee room
all the speaker everyone who has turned
a card in is in favor of this bill of
this measure thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman I'm JD Bernardi uh
Rockingham 36 which is Hampton Falls
Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow so the southeast border of the
state
um the purpose of my testimony or
commentary here is uh because I'm the
sponsor of the convention of States uh
resolution which you'll hear next week
and I've received a large number of
emails
telling me that this is a illegitimate
process
and that the the entire process by which
we uh ended up with the United States
Constitution was illegitimate these
delegates did not have the authority and
power to
end the Articles of Confederation
and uh that I I want to go through a
little bit of History to dispel that
which is relevant to the entire concept
of the state's nominating and tasking
delegates to support convention work
so
the Philadelphia Convention wasn't our
first attempt to deal with the Articles
of Confederation it started in Annapolis
at a meeting titled the meeting of
Commissioners to remedy defects of the
federal government
that was in September of
1786 a year before the Philadelphia
Convention and why did they meet because
it was recognized that the states had
set up multiple barriers for uh
restricting trade all kinds of tariffs
between the different states
and so
that convention was called with respect
to dealing with that unique Soul tasking
now New Jersey New York Pennsylvania and
Delaware and Virginia showed up
New Hampshire Massachusetts Rhode Island
and North Carolina didn't make it it was
a four-day convention and they were late
so they weren't part of the convention
the other states
I apologize the representative they have
a point of order for the chair
please
thank you Mr chairman the bill before us
is on limiting The Authority of New
Hampshire delegates to policy making
conventions
and I think a friend from the
legislature is talking about how the
convention first started and people went
to the convention and it's interesting
and I and I expect to hear that when we
take up the Article 5 Bill next week but
I think now we're just focused on this
bill before us which is limiting uh the
role and I again apologize the member
for interrupting and I want to hear what
he has to say but I think it should be
given when we take up that bill and not
while we discuss this bill on limiting
uh the authority of members to any
Article 5 convention that's my point
about Mr chairman thank you
representative sherliff uh represent
Bernardo the the History part I find
very good and helpful but uh
please try to tie this into the specific
measure that is before us if you would
yes Mr chairman I understand the uh the
comment the reason for the the short
diversion in history was was to make
clear that states did have the authority
to appoint
delegates to various conventions and
they followed that tasking so the
Annapolis folks followed the tasking and
at the end of their discussion they they
said we need a broader convention and
the article sent out a unanimous report
saying we need a broader convention to
discuss the issues of government
for for these 13 colonies so that was
followed the tasking was followed and
that is that is the point I mean the the
the the concern for this uh Bill and and
I think uh Senator Rubens made the point
was we need to establish trust in this
process and and we as he already
indicated we already have that Authority
as a legislature to to address
a tasking for a convention or other
Interstate uh compact type issues but
let in order to ensure that we have
cemented that trust we use the this this
bill as the belt and suspenders as he
said to ensure that we
that that the the citizens of New
Hampshire will agree that yes the
legislature has the authority the
legislature has the ability to do the
tasking and the legislature has the
ability to hold those delegates
accountable
that's the purpose of this bill and
that's the purpose and the reason for
going through the history is to say we
did it then and we can do it again
thank you representative
questions from the committee
saying that I thank you for your
testimony uh Senator rubin's earlier
reference someone from Wolf Pack
wolf-p-a-c I believe that might be uh
Samuel Filman who is here uh asked for
four minutes and uh
Mr Phil you have four minutes
that you asked for
and maybe more
if necessary
my name is Samuel fieldman I'm National
Council for Wolf Pack I've been studying
the issue of these kinds of conventions
since uh 2010 uh when my kids were not
quite born yet uh they just turned 11.
um and you know these issues are near
and dear to my heart
um I want to specifically talk about in
the bill before us the moment uh
2c3 section 2 uh representative Porcelli
talked about a Supreme Court case uh
cfollow and that's the case that this
language comes from but I want to give
you a little bit of the history of how
that language got to where it is today
and in doing so that will also help you
better understand the different types of
conventions this bill deals with not
only Article 5 conventions but all types
of Interstate conventions and it will
also help you understand the why we know
that this kind of limiting procedure is
possible first I'm very honored to be
telling the story before representative
Kerry town crier of pascala New
Hampshire because my Story begins right
after representative Bernardi uh his
story and it begins in that very Town
um the article the U.S Constitution
under has three different types of
conventions it has two under Article 5
for ratification and for proposing and
it also has conventions under article 7.
the article 7 ratifying convention
ratified the US Constitution itself and
those were held in the various States
after uh the after the Constitution was
proposed by the convention and by
Congress
um in the town in the state of New
Hampshire
there were people who had very strong
feelings on both sides about the this
new Constitution and
um they especially the overwhelming
majority really opposed the new
Constitution which is why some of the
Federalists tried every trick in the
book that they could think of holding
the the convention in the middle of um
of a brutal New Hampshire winter in the
Federalist controlled area where people
had to travel up to 200 miles to get
there through the snow
but it really mattered to people at the
time and it's still these kinds of
things matter to us today uh which is
why towns met elect delegates sent their
delegates and towns also instructed
their delegates specifically on the
issue and many of the towns constructed
their delegates to vote no to vote
against the U.S Constitution when they
got to the to the original convention in
New Hampshire they found that they
didn't have enough delegates to vote for
it but they also found that once the
delegates were talking about the policy
many of them found that they wish they
had different instructions that they
wished they could vote Yes for the
Constitution but they couldn't because
the instructions were they were Bound by
their instructions and the instructions
were enforceable so they traveled back
through the New Hampshire winter back to
their towns and in the town of biscawan
in particular
the the people there had instructed
their delegates to vote no on uh their
delegate to vote no on the on the
Constitution
um and he said you know if if you send
me back I'm going to vote Yes
um and they recognized in that town
their inherent authority to replace that
delegate with somebody else who would
follow the right procedure they had
another candidate all picked out who was
ready and willing and they ultimately
decided that they would trust their
delegate to vote his conscience and they
would abide by that even if they were
less certain about about that position
they trusted his knowledge and they
decided to do that but they recognized
that they had the authority to limit
that delegate if uh if they so chose
um fast forward to the conventions that
uh that Senator Rubens talked about uh
this time Article 5 conventions for
ratification of the um of the uh
Amendment of the 21st amendment
um in that case as as you asked how to
how did we figure out these things well
they were kind of scrambling because
Congress called for an amendment and
called for it to be for the first time
ever ratified by Article 5 ratification
conventions and people didn't know how
the Article 5 convention process worked
in this case the ratification
conventions as opposed to the as opposed
to the amendment proposing convention
and there was a lot of fear about that
and States ended up scrambling to put
together whatever the best delegate
limitation rules that they could
um the book that representative that
Senator Rubens talked about
provides all of the laws passed by all
the different states and nearly all of
them had some sort of mechanism or other
of delegate limitations but only one of
them hit on the gold standard all of
them were effective none of the
delegates ran away but one of them hit
on the gold standard for for how to do
it and it was this precise procedure
that was the state of Arizona where if a
delegate ran away from their
instructions they would be removed their
vote would be invalidated and that and
that they would then be replaced with an
alternate who would vote according to
how they were instructed
um uh that didn't end up needing to
happen
um but that exact language was later
adopted by neighboring state New Mexico
uh for uh for a different type of
Interstate convention in this case uh
the um the Electoral College
um and the electricity Electoral College
similar to delegates to a convention I
also are generally instructed uh to uh
by their various States and they have
the same language there and in this case
uh one of the delegates in New Mexico
did not want to vote for uh the person
who for I believe it was Hillary Clinton
uh that their state had voted for and
instead voted for Colin Powell that
delegates vote was invalidated it never
counted was not counted by Congress when
they they met to count the votes and
they were replaced by an alternate who
voted as the state had instructed them
to do and that was upheld unanimously by
the Supreme Court
um and you know this is in a very
divided Supreme Court but it was upheld
unanimously just in 2020 and that's the
language that is now in in this bill and
it's a language that's increasingly
being adopted by more and more States as
they're looking at this and being
proposed in more and more States and
it's incredibly important to have that
kind of um that kind of bill pass ahead
of time well certainly states have
demonstrated that when an article 5
convention happens as happened in 1933
with the Article 5 ratifying conventions
they are able to very quickly come up
with uh with a regulatory scheme pass a
bill and handle it and it worked
absolutely wonderfully without without a
flaw then it's better to do it ahead of
time when you're not under that time
pressure and that's why I'm in support
of this bill
take some some questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you for being here
from wolf pack is Pac political action
committee not p-a-c-k correct oh yes
okay uh we have three more cards we do
have a card uh from a an individual
posing the bill which I want to go to
right now that is a representative uh
from Loudoun Alvin C
who asked for three minutes
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm Alvin Z I represent
Merrimack 26 which goes from loud and
over to Danbury if you want all eight
town named I'll give them to you I'm in
opposition to this
when the enough states which is 34
request the U.S Congress for an article
5 convention
the U.S archives is tasked with counting
to make sure that there are those States
and there's correct number of states
um then the U.S Congress sets the
conditions of the convention and the
same Congress determines the
qualifications of delegates and
determines how they will be selected
an article 5 convention
uh is a federal function not a state
function as such this bill has no
control and therefore this bill provides
false confidence in New Hampshire's
ability to control the delegates
also in uh some of the written testimony
that's been provided online uh it was
talked about it only takes 13 or more
states to reject any
changes but if a new con a new
constitution is proposed the new
constitution may have different
requirements for
adopting it and therefore the 13 states
may not be enough
so that's that's why I'm opposed to this
because it gives a misleading
uh confidence in in our ability to do
anything about a runaway convention
thank you I'll take questions if any are
there any questions from the committee
C9 thank you representative
leave two more cards both in support of
the bill I'm looking at uh William Jolly
William is in the back and he's coming
to the front
voice
from Groton New Hampshire popular
population 700
unless somebody was born or died today
so
um
so thank you very much uh my my 15 year
old daughter is trying to make me groovy
but I don't think it's working I and the
reason I tell you that is I'm going to
use my phone to read to you but I had to
go next door and borrow some
reading glasses so I got I don't think
I'm groovy uh
and I don't even know if that's a word
anymore so uh ladies and gentlemen thank
you okay that's not working ladies and
gentlemen thank you for an opportunity
for all of us to speak to this
um
yeah I I'm a soldier I was a soldier I'm
retired I guess I'm still in the retired
reserve and uh
I get a little worked up here thinking
about the people who spoke earlier the
heroes that got shot at blown up things
like that came here to testify before
you
um one of the things that was a a
resonating message from them and it's
the observation of the people and we are
a government of them by and for the
people
is that they don't feel they're being
represented by their Congress because
the Congress abandoned their
responsibility and delegated it to the
executive
also he was an act of cowardice because
it is okay so when we're talking about
this stuff it's the same thing what
we're talking about when we speak to and
I will get into it and I'm I'm not a
constitutional scholar I'm a
constitutional student I've been
interested for decades but my Master's
in Business Administration it's not a
big deal so
when I look at what
we're facing and the reason for the fear
that others have mentioned is we don't
trust the institutions that we keep
saying are going to do the right thing
by us in the event of um
uh and I'll speak to the Constitutional
Convention because I was unaware that
this bill uh reaches out to other types
of conventions
we don't trust the institutions as
they're operating today
and we're looking at histories prior to
World War II which was the last time we
actually declared war so I see a thread
here and I think it's important that we
consider that because
this Constitutional Convention that we
have should serve as a check for the bad
behavior of our elected people and our
appointed people subordinate to them so
I'll get into the the verbiage of my
ramblings here I did KISS the Blarney
Stone but I've managed to tighten up my
speech quite a bit so I won't be too
long I promise uh so I'll just read even
though some of it's repetitive thank you
ladies and gentlemen for the opportunity
to speak in this my name is William
Jolly
um I'm a resident of Groton I moved up
from Boston uh my house looked at the
rail I would have looked at the rail of
the uh Bunker Hill battle which is
actually on breeds Hill so I moved up
here thinking things are going to be
pretty conservative and I hope we can
keep things in check and have truly
purple rather than one color extreme or
another but I in full disclosure I'm
here as an individual and I am a uh uh
we have a different title for it in
Grafton County I'm a delegate to the
state Republican committee so but I'm
here as an individual I'm not
representing them in my statements right
now
professionally
professionally I'm an insurance broker
in an earlier life I mentioned I was a
soldier in one of my last jobs over 32
years as a soldier and prior to that in
Navy Seabee was as a tactical
information operations planner and
instructor at Norwich University and so
I worked on staffs uh doing stuff that
we won't get into but it was it was
pretty heavy stuff one of my jobs is one
that you folks have right now and that
was too you may have heard of this sir
that was to analyze assess and find ways
to mitigate second and third order
effects risks
and introduce them this bill does that
I'm one of the people that does not have
confidence in in the security of an
article 5 convention right now
um so I'm obviously I'm here to uh say
it should uh should be ought to pass but
by
all appearances there are three reasons
uh why I'm in favor of this in Article 5
conventional States should be relied
upon as a check on the federal
government but the founders left us with
very little uh to work with as to what
this thing looks like when it's done how
is it structured there is some language
out there
none of it is law it's all experience
and and in some cases conjecture uh
there's currently no solid check on
potential Rogues to an article 5
convention
uh by at least not by New Hampshire and
there's not sufficient checks to Rogues
across the several States right so it's
if we have a number of people that band
together and we in 15 other states have
our check in place is that going to be
adequate so I'm not I'm not saying that
this is a Panacea for for what we face
but I think it's an important Cog in the
wheel
um there is a potential for a rogue
delegate or delegation from the majority
of States including New Hampshire right
now to behave in a manner inconsistent
with the intent of individual State
legislatures there's currently no solid
check on potential Rogues lastly a
majority of states with legislation like
this proposal are better yet adoption by
all the states with something similar to
our proposed piece will provide a
measure although incomplete of
mitigation of the risk of a runaway
Convention of states
as I mentioned I'm not a constitutional
scholar but I do I do have a lot of
passion for it and like a lot of people
behind me and probably a lot of you I
pay attention to it and I study it
um
one of the people that we should be
looking to is someone who's is
considered a constitutional scholar and
that's Justice Berger U.S Supreme Court
Justice Berger served from the late
1960s to the late 1980s he was a
Republican appointee and he wrote
there is no effective way to limit or
muzzle the actions of a constitutional
convention
the convention could make its own rules
and set its own agenda Congress might
try to limit the convention to one
Amendment or to one issue which is
probably a good thing but there is no
way to assure that the convention would
obey
after a convention is convened it is too
late to stay uh to stop the convention
if we don't like its agenda so again I I
don't there are people that uh disagree
with what this Justice said and they're
going to speak later but he was a
Supreme Court Justice he couldn't have
been a knucklehead part of English and
he uh and he probably had some some
references that he could cite in order
to support his argument so
and I'll wrap this up pretty quickly the
potential for a Convention of States
this is my words the potential for a
Convention of States should be relied
upon as a check for the three branches
of federal government
without an ability for states to control
their delegates we are at risk for
unanticipated outcomes
this absence of guidance and experience
juxtaposed with the abundance of
unconstitutional Behavior exhibited by
people around the nation empowered at
the federal and state levels today
events is a need for good people to
create protections that's you guys to
create protections for the constituents
this is an opportunity for you adoption
of HB 269 is a statute will be a step in
the right direction for New Hampshire to
protect us from having to debate with
uncertain outcomes proposed bad
amendments and to serve as a good model
for other states in particular within
the body and this this is critical I
think that we have this thing called
center of gravity what that is is
basically the thing that's going to make
this really really a valuable tool the
center of gravity to this would be a C3
subsection two and where they talk about
nullification because there isn't a lot
of language about that out there and if
we can nullify prior to the bad behavior
we have a better argument when it would
probably go to the U.S Supreme Court so
that's not based on my legal experience
because I don't have any but based on my
observations so that's all I have
pending your questions thank you for
your time
thank you for coming down from Groton
questions for the speaker
all right thank you seeing none your
daughter can review the video as to uh
your grooving this so she's not allowed
to see this because it'll be
never-ending judgment thank you
here uh uh is from um Ken Quinn Ken is
Ken here yes he is
submitted
that online
yes thank you Kenny saw that and it's
much appreciated great information and
we all have that in our inboxes
is there anyone else who wants to speak
to this measure
uh Senator uh Rubens uh you can have you
have a half a minute
yep
illa's question which Ken has provided
information there are 15 states that
have existing uh delegate limitation
laws in place
and you can find them Ken's testimony
and uh in in one of my hyperlinks you
can see a list of those states and their
laws how they're structured
thank you Senator and again the uh
the testimony submitted electronically
it's I've already looked at some of that
is is much appreciated it gives us a
chance to go back over the next week and
look at it and review it all right at
this time I will end this session we
will come back at one o'clock 1300 with
representative McGuire's uh measure HB
330. there is a a uh informational
session at upper Walker on some of this
material that you're all welcome to
attend and we'll see you at one o'clock
okay these are four o'clock Madam Clerk
you try to get over to
you okay I know
they put they
and rulemaking and then we were slated
for in 1 pm hcr3
representative Gerard Gerhard is in the
house
thank you
[Music]
the prime sponsor did ask for three
minutes
and I have Colonel Grady's card as well
who asked similarly for three minutes
General michaelitis is here yeah uh
three minutes
and Warren Perry only asked for two
minutes uh when we get when we get there
that's uh
brevity is the source of something some
wise person said again
um
just waiting for uh the prime sponsor
for
3 30.
thank you sir
foreign
hey folks I do want to honor your time
and um
if
if I might I what I'm going to do so
that we can we can start the uh the
process here I'm going to call this
session to order for HB 330.
um and I will in effect uh introduce the
measure and then when the prime sponsor
hopefully if the prime sponsor comes by
she is here as we speak welcome uh uh
Senator welcome representative McGuire
and thank you for your forbearance this
morning there's a great deal of interest
in the declaration of war issue which is
a weighty issue so we want to make sure
everyone had a chance to speak to that
on the snowy day where some folks
traveled a good distance
so welcome uh Russell McGuire this is uh
HP 330 Dash fn-a relative to the
National Guard recruitment incentive
program it's funding in rulemaking
welcome thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm Carol McGuire
Merrimack District 27 which is
Allenstown Dunbarton Epsom and Hooksett
and House Bill 330 is a request of the
Department of Veterans Affairs
because they brought a rule on their
incentive program to gel car
it's the only
only case where they were required to to
go through the formal rulemaking process
and gel Carr couldn't figure out why
they should be required to do so
so this bill started as
simply deleting the
541a reference on page one line 28 and
said
you have rules
we'll um will follow
that's that's good enough they don't
need to go through legislative approval
and while we were at it
I also
at their request added that the any
fines that they collect would go into
their enlistment incentive fund
but
um
didn't seem like a big deal and
increased the uh incentive payment from
500 to a thousand dollars because of
inflation
and I will try to
answer any questions you may have but I
hope the department will have the
details
questions for the prime sponsor
yes representative Lloyd thank you Mr
chair German
um so my question and thank you my
question is in regards to the the fines
collected
um I recognize recruitment the costs
have gone up across the board in every
industry industry possible right now
um but and and I appreciate the attempt
to mitigate the costs of these but um
can you tell me more about where like
these fines are currently
um allocated to
um
they go into the general fund and
they're allocated along with every other
uh state fund all right are they
subjective at all or like are they I'm
afraid I don't know that
I can ask others thank you okay
thank you representative I had a similar
question I was going to hold off for the
the General michaelitis on I had to find
question as well a fine question a
question about fines is you know okay
that's a pretty good action too yeah the
vice chair had a similar question about
fines that so General that stand by for
fine questions find questions uh other
questions for the prime sponsor
seeing none thank you representative
McGuire
thank you
okay General uh General michaelitis
thank you for being here
but hey Mr chairman committee members
for the record I'm David michaelitis
general for the New Hampshire National
Guard
um so as a representative alluded to
this bill does three things right it
increases a current statute to increase
our enlistment incentive program from
500 to a thousand
and number two is it removes that gel
car sort of responsibility to do the
rule making process because generally
speaking the department of military
Affairs is veteran services is exempt
from rulemaking except for the specific
statute to apply to this in the last
legislative session and the third thing
was uh Mr Perry will specifically answer
your question ma'am in regards to the
the fines conceptually when a soldier uh
gets an Article 15 he gets in trouble
during a drill status
um he pays a fine for whatever that
infraction may occur we used to apply
those funds to our scholarship found
account we no longer have a scholarship
account because of tuition waiver that
we offer our service members at the
University system of New Hampshire
so it now goes into the general funds
um it's a sort of a nominal fee I'd say
a thousand to five thousand dollars so
instead of it just going to the general
fund it would come back into this
account
the primary thing I'd like to talk about
is mostly about the why it's going from
500 to a thousand dollars
um you have my written testimony then
behind that is some updated information
about the current recruiting market and
as I alluded to in an earlier
conversation with you all about a week
ago
um there is no line on our door we're
we're a word of mouth business or a
family business eighty percent of new
recruits come from a military family but
we're also referral business so by
referrals is our best recruiting
advertisement is Word of Mouth
Six States in the country have gone to
this enlistment incentive program the
closest state is Vermont
um when we had this legislation passed
last cycle it was for 500 it's not
having an impact as much as we would
have hoped
um so we think we need to elevate it to
a thousand dollars to be more comparable
to have have a bigger impact to getting
referrals sent to us right now we have
about it when this came in effect after
the rulemaking process we've been uh
doing this for about two months now
um a soldier Airman has not shipped yet
so we have not actually given out any
money as an incentive during this
incentive program but we anticipate that
happening in the next month or two
that's pretty much subject to the
questions that's all I have
thank you sir uh questions for Major
General michaelitis
yes representative minion
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question
um so if you increase the incentive
program is it possible that the money
isn't an issue and people don't want to
join the National Guard and then deploy
to war zones let's say
uh no
it it's um
I I no I don't think so
representative Finney thank you Mr chair
uh sir I just have one one question
about uh one specific part in line 15
here it says that
Uh current
uh members of the National Guard in the
pay grades of E1 to O3
um I just want to know what the
rationale is uh between allowing
officers who uh would already make us a
significant amount of money or realistic
person would be allowed to take
advantage of an incentive program
uh so so we try to keep it to the junior
officers like lieutenants and an O3 is
obviously a captain
um captains uh don't make that much as
much money as a senior officer and the
rationale was we still need officers to
join our formation
so we still need if the officer goes to
college and he's a second Lieutenant
he's in ROTC and he's a simultaneous
Member Program at SMP Cadet uh that's a
referral to us
so that you know that's lieutenants you
know we need that too
the follow-ups
follow up
um isn't it true sir that um commission
offices whether they're senior or not
still taking more more benefits of their
commission over a little person
uh probably financially but the benefits
of the benefits for any service member
whether Army Air generally speaking
whether it's like you know for example
Congress passed 12 weeks of Parental
leave they don't discriminate between
illicitor officer
thanks sir
other questions
uh representative Kerry
just the mundane one um can you spell
your name please
oh I just yeah went off the end of the
card
m-i-k yep o l a i
t i e s
I'll get it eventually okay
we stress attention to detail here in
state federal records
other questions
thank you so much sir thank you
uh Lauren Perry is still in the house
welcome back Mr Perry
for the record uh Warren Perry Deputy
General New Hampshire Department of
military Affairs and veteran services I
want to talk specifically about the
rulemaking piece of this so in in the
written testimony uh that that you see
you'll note that RSA 110b
um eight exempts the department from all
rulemaking and we love that exemption by
the way we think it's the best thing in
the whole world but there are two parts
of our statute that had subsequent uh to
to 110 B8 being passed had rule making
requirements right one is for the
tuition waiver program or the
post-secondary education program and
those rules are contingent on those
rules administrative rules at the edge
in general deems necessary and luckily
he doesn't deem any necessary now but we
still want to clean up the statute
when the appropriation came for this
particular program the legislation this
legislature the general court was
probably not aware of the general
exemption and in their standard
legislative language added a requirement
for us to to write administrative rules
and I will tell you that process is very
arduous
and 541 says that rules only apply when
they apply to the General Public
right so you know if it's going to have
something binding on the general public
and the populations that we deal with
are not necessarily the general public
they are current and former members of
the New Hampshire National Guard and not
binding on the general public and that's
generally the rationale that when we
talk to the folks at uh at legislative
services and we talked to the folks at
gel car they said let's clean this up so
that's really the rationale by which we
want to eliminate this rulemaking
requirement we it's not that we don't
want legislative oversight because we
love it but in this particular case the
rulemaking requirements are are you know
to get that done it's it's an arduous
process and it takes a lot of time it
took about
16 months just to get through to get the
rules that we have now to be able to do
this so what we'd like to do is just do
away with that rulemaking requirement we
don't think it's too much of an ask and
we'd ask you from that perspective to be
able to to eliminate this the second
thing I'd like to say is there's part of
this statute or part of this bill
that makes this uh appropriation
continuous and non-lapsing and that just
eliminates our need to go back every
time we pay one of these bills if we
want to be paid one of these incentives
not to have to go back to the to the
executive Council to pay it so if we
have that language in here that would
just reduce our administrative burden as
we do this again not that we don't want
the oversight we absolutely do we know
that you know the potential for fraud
exists in these kinds of programs we
want to have great oversight but every
time we pay one of these benefits it
will delay the payment and and everybody
knows that reward is best when it's
immediately given so we'd like to not
have to do that in order to make those
payments and those are the two things
that I'd like to talk about or I wanted
to talk about here so subject to your
questions and I'll be happy to address
your fine question uh but subject to
your questions I'll uh and I will that
concludes my testimony I'll be happy to
answer any questions
thank you Mr Perry
um back to the Fine question that uh
representative Lloyd brought up
representative Rollins
also expressed some interest and I I
know from my experience with Article 15
and JP what we call office hours it
would be fines so I hadn't thought of
this until just now but uh I I'm some of
us may be curious as to if you could
quantify the uh the amount of potential
fine uh funds uh is it miniscule or
significant if you know it's less than
five thousand dollars a year
so I would say minuscule and I would I
don't have the exact number off my top
of my head I will be sure to email that
I'll go back to the financial manager
but it's not much probably I think on
average somewhere between 12 and 1800 a
year and fines to get levied
I wanna and that's not all to one person
by the way I mean that's that's spread
over anybody who gets in trouble
because that kind of touch on your
question
somewhat um I guess I'm looking at this
I've I've been working in non-profit
Finance for 14 years
um so I'm very attuned to where things
are allocated and budgets um so I guess
my concern here would be to prevent any
real or perceived impropriety as far as
imposition of fines
on to people and this being a need-based
service because I know that as far as
recruitment goes our recruitment we need
to have that going on so you're kind of
saying like the town needs to make up
their their their shortfall so they
write more speeding tickets is that kind
of where you're going bent that so
assumption so so we don't you know
levying non-judicial punishment or
article 15s or general course Marshall
is a legal process subject to legal and
due process rules outlined in RSA 110b
starting at 110 B 39 and those processes
mirror the uniform code of military
justice so without a lawyer without due
process without an appellate process we
don't do this so the generally focused
at misconduct and minor misconduct so
non-criminal misconduct is generally
where these these fines are levied and
we're not going out to punish people so
that we can fill this fund I can assure
you that that's not going to happen
we're more concerned that we get the 50
000 dollars appropriation that we put in
our budget to get this funded
I hope I hope I've answered your
question
follow up
um so with that
um that's great to hear um but the other
question is are there any other
budgetary items that could potentially
use these funds and then reallocate
those funds from another portion that
would be less need based I'm not sure I
understand your question so like if um
so these fines
um again to avoid any perceived
impropriety of use of these um is there
somewhere in the budget where
um they could go that is a more static
cost that does not vary from year to
year
so they could right it's always there's
always an option to go do that I think
that it's on so from from my perspective
again I want to reassure you that it's
unlikely that we're going to increase
the amount of punishment that we give to
do this I think this is the cleanest way
to do this for context before we had the
enlistment incentive program we had a
small program that was funded at about
25 000 a year called the New Hampshire
National Guard scholarship fund and it
would supplement educational benefits it
was a redundant need so when we when we
found strategically that our biggest
strategic issue was recruiting
we decided and retention we decided to
turn that program into this
in the previous scholarship program
those fines were allocated to that
scholarship fund
so it only made sense for us to do it
this way right so we the short answer is
we didn't give any thought to giving
them anywhere else it just made sense
for them to go here but I'm going to
assure you that military Justice and
Military discipline in uniform code of
military Justice that due process that
wouldn't hold up that we just start
punishing people to fill this up I'm
telling you it would be like it would be
like the courts doing it it would be
like you know 1950s Louisiana you know
what I'm saying it would that's not
going to happen so
General Patton said something about
Louisiana but I we will go there at this
time other questions for uh
Miss Perry
thank you thank you sir
Uh Kevin Grady is is uh signed up in
support of the bill representing State
veterans advisory committee
Colonel Grady welcome back
thank you Mr chairman it's great to be
back ladies and gentlemen on the
committee again for the record my name
is Kevin Grady 25-year Air Force veteran
23-year resident of the town of Hooksett
the state veterans advisory committee
was briefed on this bill by by Colonel
Perry at our last meeting and we we
supported it pending seeing the language
and now that I've seen the language we
do wholeheartedly support this and our
20 veteran service organizations when we
Branch out and talk to other people
we're part of this this recruiting
effort for for trying to get the guard
and get folks you know because as they
said 80 percent are have some relative
that has served of the people that are
coming on active duty so I mean I'm
coming into the guard so we you know
we're we're proud to help be part of
this effort Colonel Perry called covered
all of the rule making part of this
thing and I'm not going to talk to that
because frankly as a fighter pilot
rulemaking and stuff like that makes my
head hurt so I'm gonna I'm gonna pass
that but the the increase in the amount
we we support that you know it's uh you
want to get the kids attention if you
possibly can we're also in support of
the the other bill this is the some of
the recruiting and retention piece we're
also support of Senate Bill 45 which is
uh part of the retention piece that
hopefully you'll be seeing coming this
direction soon so we do fully support
this bill and subject to your questions
that's all I wanted to tell you this
this afternoon
questions for Colonel Grady
seeing none thank you sir thanks thanks
for putting up with me is there anyone
else who like yes uh Madam chair I mean
Madam clerk I just got a promotion
um I did have one question of the Prime
sponsors I'm reflecting on some of the
testimony that has come forward
representative McGuire has any thought
been given to indexing the costs and the
the increase in the retention uh amount
such that it reflects our changing
Society so that they won't have to come
back periodically and amend us
uh
the short answer is no and the one
reason is that as long as
I mean an incentive
an incentive payment just needs to be
big enough to get someone's attention
and say yes this is this is an incentive
to make me
choose to sign up this week instead of
next week or whatever
I wouldn't expect it to be
straight out indexed that's the not the
purpose of an incentive payment but it
will give it a few years and see if it's
if well the need for the incentive also
changes
right now with the need for incentives
is very high
in the future it may become less
necessary I mean if we have a major
recession and people are looking for
jobs I'm sure that the
the recruitment will be much easier
so I think that it's up to the
Department to decide if they need to
adjust the amount to be to make it
functional
does anyone else wish to speak to this
measure
uh Miss Perry
to representative Maguire's point I
would just say that the the incentive
program is contingent on the general
court approving an appropriation so
that's another way we can index
thank you
seeing no more
potential speakers we will call a close
to this hearing on
on HB 330 and we'll plunge ahead to uh
hcr3 house concurrent resolution 3 the
prime sponsor of that measure is here
welcome representative Gerhard
yeah
thank you chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Jason Gerhard represent mayor Mack 25
towns of Northfield and Franklin
so I know we're really behind schedule
I'm going to streamline this I know it's
a long bill
the key part of this I believe is
article 7 of the State Constitution
State sovereignty real quick the people
of the state have the sole and exclusive
right of governing themselves as a free
Sovereign and independent state and do
and forever Hereafter shall exercise and
enjoy every Power of jurisdiction and
rape pertaining there too which is not
or may not here after be by them
expressly delegated to the United States
American Congress assembled
so
we've come very far from that I believe
it's 46 of our funding for the state
government comes from the federal
government now
much of it with strings attached
and much of it introduced through the
executive council with little oversight
just due to the sheer volume of money
coming in which is unfortunate so this
bill
basically says we got to kind of go back
to where we came from and really
look back to the spirit
with which the Constitution State
Constitution and the Federal
Constitution were adopted
and I like to ask myself would people
nowadays be willing to join the Federal
Union as it stands
if we took a vote would people really
want to sign up for what we have going
on from all the unconstitutional Wars to
just the sheer bureaucratic mess I mean
look at the IRS it just the things have
gotten so
nobody really knows what's going on
that's my basic point just due to the
sheer volume
and thankfully New Hampshire with 400
State reps we have a much more Hands-On
approach to state government which is
great it really is so last part this is
the final paragraph of the bill line 20
that faithful to that compact according
to the plain intent and meaning in which
it was understood and is seated to by
the several parties it is sincerely
anxious for its preservation that it
also does believe that to take from the
states all the powers of self-government
and transfer them to a general and
Consolidated Government without regard
to the special delegations and
reservations solemnly agreed to in that
compact is not for the peace happiness
or prosperity of these states and that
therefore this state is determined as
its doubts not its coast states are to
submit to undelegated and consequently
unlimited powers and no man or body of
men on Earth that in cases of an abuse
of the delegated powers the members of
the general government being chosen by
the people A Change by the people would
be the Constitutional remedy but where
powers are assumed which have not been
delegated a nullification is the act
of the ACT is the rightful remedy that
every state is a natural right and cases
not within the compact to nullify of
their own authority all assumptions of
Power by others within their limits that
without this right they would be under
the Dominion absolute and unlimited of
whoever might exercise this right of
judgment for them
and that's basically the gist of what
the uh the rationale behind this bill
because if we're not if we're not going
to establish ourselves a sovereign
independent state what's the point we're
just an administrative unit of the
federal government so let's just disband
state government
save ourselves the money and just let's
go from there because I just don't see
the point anymore so otherwise we're
just doing we're just doing like cosplay
you know we're just kind of it's all
theater so yeah so if you have any
questions I'd appreciate it and that's
that thank you
thank you representative uh I have a
question and there may be some others to
follow and I know we have at least one
person one other person has signed up to
speak
um all the whereas is uh
I want to reread those I think any
resolution the whereas is uh really make
the case for that but my question to you
is um from what you just read
um on line 30 it mentions the
Nullification of the ACT to
nullification of the ACT is the rifle
remedy in other words as I understand
what you just read
um
the action that it is needed to be taken
is a nullification in other words
essentially cancellation
so it would be helpful to visualize
or to get your vision of this if you
could give us a like a specific example
of something that might be nullified so
that I or weak and better understand how
this might be implemented well let's use
a let's say a minimal example I think
it's kind of funny at a state of Montana
so the feds came in and said if you want
your state funding I'm sorry the highway
funds they had to Institute a speed
limit so Montana said okay they create a
law that going over this the speed limit
would be wasting of Natural Resources
it's like a 50 fine they never issued
one ticket so that's how states can
nullify Federal overreach they play
these games where they collect the money
for us allegedly and say you want the
money back you got to dance so at a
certain point how many how far will you
go before you say okay we're not really
independent at this point none of the
stuff that they're doing is
constitutional let's look at in line
ah here it is page two line nine
whereas the Constitution United States
having delegated to Congress to power to
punish treason counterfeiting the
Securities and current coin in the
United States piracies and felonies
committed on the high seas offense
against the law of Nations and slavery
and no other crimes whatsoever
now we can argue that there's some good
federal laws on the books but why aren't
we enacting those laws
if they're so important to us
when you say we you're talking about the
state level yes I thought we were having
a conversation I'm addressing yes so
sure
question other questions for the prime
sponsor
saying none thank you representative
thank you very much thank you for your
time have a uh card here from uh Frank
Staples of Manchester is Frank here
so yeah I support I support this bill uh
I'll try to be brief you were asking uh
representative Gerhard to explain
nullification
I would suggest going to the 10th
amendmentcenter.com they also have a lot
of YouTube videos and they cover all the
different legislation uh the
Nullification legislation that gets put
forth across the 50 states a number of
these uh here in New Hampshire have been
featured on this guy's website and
YouTube channel
and he explains it very well and there's
different ways to nullify number one is
nullifying in the first person I've been
nullifying
um
the courts trying to ban people from
filming okay I've been doing that the
cops get called Supreme Court hits the
emergency button there's no law
the Supreme one of the Supreme Court
Justices just put out this order saying
that nobody can film and they use rule
19 as the backing in rule 19 actually
gives us the right to film in court
so these are the ways to nullify
legislation is you guys's job me I
nullify in person I speak with my feet
and I do not obey unconstitutional laws
okay and
the New Hampshire Constitution is more
protective than the Federal Constitution
we all know this I hope
and supremacy clause defers to the ninth
and Tenth Amendment which gives New
Hampshire
Constitution Supremacy over New
Hampshire citizens as well as the people
of New Hampshire
and I believe I don't know how this
could be implemented at anything but
we should not be arguing from federal
law in this state ever because of the
fact that our state constitution is more
protective on religion firearms and
everything else we have the right to
Revolution built in
I mean it goes on and on so I don't know
if there could be something put in there
in this this article 7 that says we have
Supremacy and that all cases should be
argued from the state constitution and
not the Federal Constitution because we
are more protective and uh that's all I
have to say thank you
would you submit any questions sure
someone have any questions Staples
say none thank you for taking the time
to speak to us today
appreciate that
does anyone else
would anyone else like to speak to this
measure
okay seeing none
we will end this hearing on hcr3 which
will bring us to hcr4 which actually is
scheduled for 1 45 interestingly
so we have uh a six minute break uh
before we can uh take that up
okay
thank you
foreign
it's
um
thank you
yeah you're cooking supper and pour me a
glass of wine
yes
foreign okay it being 145 146 uh we will
move to uh the next measure house
concurrent resolution for
the prime sponsor reps and Wallace is
here welcome representative Wallace
thank you chairman moffatt members of
the committee colleagues
um for the record my name is
representative Scott Wallace Rockingham
County District 8 not 33 as it says on
the bill in front of you that is the
town of Danville
and just further clarification this may
be an older resolution for some reason
as I haven't represented District 33 in
six years uh but that being said the
content of the the bill is correct
um before you house concurrent
resolution 4 is urging Congress to call
an article 5 Convention of the states
for the purpose of establishing term
limits for congress and federal
bureaucracies and office holders
um
although New Hampshire has not been
directly impacted by long-serving
members of our federal delegation we've
been indirectly impacted by long-term
long long-serving members of other
states
that have defeated many measures that
would have helped the state long term
Congress is out of control control I
think we're all in agreeance on that and
something needs to be done
Congress will never rein in itself as
evidenced by the fact that they have
proposed terminals on themselves more
than 275 times over the last 275 years
so expecting them to reign in their own
uh abuse of power is analogous of
expecting a drug addict to seek
treatment on their own volition I don't
think that's going to happen so we're
going to ask Congress I mean the several
states to bring in their power through
Article Five and I'll be happy to take
any questions
thank you representative questions for
the prime sponsor representative
Lundgren
uh thank you uh how many states
do you know of right now that are are
instituting this or trying to
from at this point in time there are I
believe 11 or 13 states with term limits
resolutions uh valid and being held at
the clerk of Congress
representative Rollins
thank you Mr chair how long do you how
long would you propose for terms how
many terms for the Senate and how many
terms would you give to the house that's
going to be a reasonable answer for that
well thank you for the question it's an
excellent question but that is not going
to be determined here or today that
would be determined once the convention
is called and the several States would
have input to that at this point in time
the the uh consensus is that it would
likely be three terms in Congress
um and two terms in the senate for a
total of uh 12 in each body with a break
in between so you could serve in
Congress for
uh you know 12 years take a break of a
term and then go serve in the upper
chamber in the Senate if you were
fortunate enough to do that the idea is
to break the uh the Stranglehold that
many of these members have on the uh on
the on Congress
okay thank you
other questions for the prime sponsor
seeing uh thank you representative
Wallace thank you
former Senator Rubens is still with us
and he has signed up in support of the
bill
uh Senator Rubens
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to
submit the same written testimony that I
did this morning did anyone not get it
they're all good
so thank you for that so I'm not going
to repeat any of that except to say that
I'm in favor a little background again
I'm in favor of all the three major
amendments that are very popular with
the American public term limits fiscal
restraint and a fix some kind of limit
to campaign money
all of these three issues are supported
by super majorities of Americans in both
parties poll after poll over over a long
period of time but replicated this and
Congress won't act on these so here's
going back to my experience I've been
involved in the amending movement for
all of these for a solid 10 years plus
and so I've been able to generate
meetings with members of Congress on
what I called a grand bargain which was
to have a term limits Bill and a
campaign finance bill which are
typically two different uh two different
resolutions before Congress to amend the
Constitution one of them term limits
tends to be supported more by
Republicans the campaign money Amendment
tends in the last session of Congress
supported by every Democratic member of
Congress So I says let's let's go in and
meet with some Republicans and Democrats
on the subject of pairing the two
amendments together in Congress we had
some great meetings those of us who had
these meetings with actual members of
Congress took a while to get them and
they they thought this idea is great
wonderful and so we'd follow up in a
week or two they'd say they'd get back
to we'd follow up a week or two later
three weeks later nothing radio silence
what happened is we finally got the
report they took the concept up to up to
leadership both the Democrat and
Republican leadership of the House and
Senate and vetoed
because the system that Congress has
right now of unlimited debt unlimited
terms of office unlimited Federal power
they love it and Leadership loves the
system they have right now and so the
the the lesson of all this in my 10
years of attempts with these kind of
btices Congress is not going to give
people
what the people of America want on any
of the three subjects term limits
campaign money reform and debt limits
Congress is not going to do that for
itself and so I'm arguing in the case
for for this particular hcr4 this is the
framers gave us this power
because in it they foresaw that Congress
could One Day become as I mentioned this
morning become unaccountable or even you
could call it corrupt unresponsive to
the will of the people so this power was
given to the states to in the case of
New Hampshire should you uh should you
uh propose and uh and and and agree to
this hcr4 this gives you the appointed
the ability should 34 States agree to
this subject matter to appoint delegates
they will be limited to debating the
subject matter at hand here and
determining what kind of term limits uh
the delegates would prefer to see but
and again I'm rebutting rebutting what
the opponents have said to this bill
this amending convention limited to that
single subject
even if they ran away they have no power
to do anything anything that a
convention for proposing amendments
might propose no matter how weird no
matter how how good it has no force in
effect until subsequently ratified by
three quarter three thirty eight states
this amending convention that people are
some people are generating so much fear
about it has no power whatsoever it can
only propose just like we here are
proposing this bill to you we have no
power you're the people who decide so
the so the the fact of the matter is
that 13 of 99 legislative bodies around
the country have absolute veto power
over anything that might be proposed by
an amending convention on any subject
whatsoever run away or or limited
properly and that means that any
proposed amendment including on-term
limits here must be massively supported
by the public across the ideological
specter term otherwise it's Dead on
Arrival so I would encourage you folks
there is an appetite by the public to
see debate and the generation of
language with respect to term limits
that would be that would be wrestled out
by by delegates to this convention
proposing amendments see if they can
come up some great language and see if
the state's 38 of which are required to
ratify have an appetite for this luck
the public express its will through you
folks who will who will Who will appoint
the delegates and I I have confidence in
you folks to to to to appoint delegates
who will be constructive who will be
creative who will listen to all sides of
the equation recognizing that all the
work they're doing is Dead on Arrival
unless it makes sense to a broad broad
swath of Americans so I heartily
heartily endorse an ought to pass on
this Bill thank you
you take any questions of course of
course okay Sarah I have one and there
may be others to follow my my question I
I could have asked the prime as well
uh we have amended our constitution in
the past uh we've put a term limits uh
amendment in with regard to the chief
executive is a presidential tournament
is an amendment constitutional amendment
that came about in the more traditional
fashion yeah now that measure that
amendment when it passed did not apply
to the president which was Truman at the
time
um it would have it did
apply to subsequent presidents but not
the current president so my question is
if if some sort of a term limits measure
was to move forward in in this this
other uh through this other mechanism
would it immediate when would it would
it affect uh how would it affect
existing office holders that would be up
to the delegates at the amending
convention to to wrestle out that
question what the terms of office might
be what offices it might apply to
whether it be uh applying to existing
members or not and and they would use a
great deal of judgment and again they'd
be they'd be looking at what works what
is the best for the American people what
might get ratified so I those questions
will be answered by the delegates which
is why again I'm trusting you folks you
are the people who will determine the
kind of delegates who will wrestle with
these exact kind of questions and
hopefully come up with a very workable
answer
we don't know what the answer will be
but again confidence in you folks to
appoint delegates who will work very
very hard to answer the questions
properly
I'm going to give myself a follow-up
Senator and ask you uh personally if you
were a delegate would you want this uh
amendment to apply to
um sitting sitting Senate uh or sitting
Congressional office holders what what
would what would your position be if I
could ask I I would be very aware of the
need for the 38 uh State through
ratification threshold and the the
influence of sitting members of Congress
on the decisions of those various States
and I would tend to exempt sitting
members or at least for a certain period
of time maybe another uh term that'd be
one possibility let them sit for another
office term or two
all to be worked out thank you yeah uh
other questions for uh Senator Rubens
thank you same none thank you Senator we
do have another card uh from
Samuel fieldman who spoke earlier today
representing wolf pack which is neutral
but he himself is in a report is in
support
and again wolf pack is Pac political
action committee
thank you chairman Moffett yes as you
said wolf pack is neutral on this we're
single issue organization personally I
support us term limits and I'm I'm I
know that many of the volunteers within
Wolfpack also agree with that
um the main point that I wanna I wanna
drive home is 100 of peer-reviewed
sources agree the idea that a limited
convention call could result in an
amendment on a different topic would be
like NASA failing to put a man on the
Moon by accidentally Landing him safely
on Mars
um and next week when we talk about a
different convention Bill I'm going to
get into more detail on how we know
that's true but what I want to drive
home right now with a little bit less
time is why it feels like that's the
opposite of the case why it feels like
uh so many of the reputable sources
disagree and the fact is
um there's there's a little bit of
disinformation going on about providing
fall sources and misrepresenting what
they say but the vast majority is
misinformation people who genuinely have
a mistaken belief about what many of the
sources say and there's so much of it
that it becomes difficult to sort the
good sources from the bad which is why
the the first article that I sent around
in my testimony explains exactly how to
do that it cites the reputable sources
and it explains the errors and the bad
sources
um but there's a history behind how that
came to be where the reason why we have
so many groups that have developed this
firm belief and the this information has
spread so widely
um you could go back much further but
the the bulk of it really started uh in
1979 uh specifically January 16 1979
um
at that point in time the the uh effort
for a balanced budget amendment was very
close to the the threshold uh depend of
convention calls and that's only using
convention calls that were limited to
that subject matter
um the uh and
um then the Governor Jerry Brown of
California
um came on board with the balanced
budget amendment effort in California to
try to get a convention call there now
at the time Governor Brown was uh the
scene as the main primary Challenger for
um for President Carter in the
Democratic primary and the Democratic
party in uh in the capital freaked out
completely
um they wrote a series of memos uh in
and one of them I refer to as the screen
memo in which they called for doing
several things uh they called for six
different things three of which they
they ended up doing one was holding a
hearing specifically to spread fear
about the Article 5 convention process
another was uh to uh
um to start an organization specifically
to reach out to people and spread
information about dangers of the article
5 convention process uh and the uh item
six on that list was scream which they
certainly did quite loudly I was
surprised to see that literally written
into the into the memo um circulating in
Senator Birch bai's office
um and uh that's exactly what they did
they had that hearing
um in November of that year uh despite
the fact that on that the very same day
um uh January 16 1979 uh the department
of justice under Jimmy Carter released a
memo explaining why the Article 5
convention process is safe another one
was released that was more comprehensive
by President Carter's uh Department of
Justice later that year
um and the uh excuse me uh Mr Jim point
of water yes
um with all due respect to the speaker
and this is interesting the question
before this committee is on the house
concurrent resolution 4 sending a
message to Congress to limit terms of
members of Congress and I think we're
going back over the Article Five
information
um there's nothing in this bill that I
saw that says right off about Article 5
but the heading is to send the
legislature send a message to Congress
dealing with term limitations
and so I think to go into what
transpires as far as people being sent
to an article 5 convention and where
it's been done before in false
information really is outside the scope
of the bill that is before this
committee at this time correct me if I'm
wrong I was under the impression that
this bill does call for an article 5
convention is that not correct
the measure does mention Article Five so
the point of your testimony is you're
trying to tie in this particular uh term
limits issue to an article five that's
what you the thread you're trying to tie
together yes okay sure if you can go
ahead and and finish tying that together
yes absolutely
um so many of the groups that you're
seeing testify against this now and
they've been uh testifying against
um it started with fear for the balanced
budget amendment but then um an article
specifically about U.S term limits was
written by Ronald rotunda uh the premier
expert on the US Constitution in 1996 I
believe specifically about U.S term
limits as it relates the Article 5
convention
um debunking many of these points that
had been spread up until that point for
the last 15 years
um groups that oppose the balanced
budget amendment on policy uh ended up
tying it in tying that opposition in
they found it easier to oppose the can
convention issue than to oppose the
actual our policy of the balanced budget
and then other groups on other subjects
including term limits including campaign
Finance reform which is what my group
works on ended up getting tied into that
because it was easier to attack the
process than the policy and we've seen
that with groups like the John Birch
Society and Eagle Forum on the right
with common cause and the ACLU on the
left
um people today have heard those talking
points repeated so many times from
sources that seem reputable and those
sources heard it from sources that seem
reputable it makes it very hard to tell
the good sources from the bad until you
really dive into this and when you look
at literally every single peer-reviewed
Source on the subject they're in
unanimous agreement on that first
statement I said that a new article 5
convention call in this case for term
limits limited to a specific subject
cannot possibly lead to a convention on
any other topic
yeah thank you uh questions for Samuel
thank you for your additional uh
testimony I have another card here from
from Ken Quinn Ken is in the back uh
Ken is in favor of uh hcr4
welcome
Mr chairman thank you chairman Moffett
Vice chairman Rollins and distinguished
committee members my name is Ken Quinn I
am the regional director with U.S term
limits I can't I wish I could move the
speaker because I can't see you in the
corner
okay
um now from Bridgton Maine and we have
been working on putting terminals on
Congress since the 1990s I want to give
you a little bit of history about this
because it's something that is the most
popular reform in the country today A
poll was taken last year 82 percent of
the American people support term limits
for congress and this is a non-partisan
those numbers break out at 87 percent
Republicans 83 percent Democrats and 78
percent Independents back in the 1990s
23 States passed laws putting term
limits on their own Congressional
delegations New Hampshire was one of the
23 most of those States the people did
it at The Ballot Box approved it by
voting for it here in New Hampshire the
legislature passed the law it passed
unanimously in the Senate
unfortunately what happened was the law
got challenged in Arkansas went all the
way to the U.S Supreme Court
and in the case against our organization
U.S term limits versus Thornton the U.S
Supreme Court ruled that the only way
term limits can be imposed upon members
of Congress was via Article 5 the
amending provision
now I'm not going to waste your time
reading Article Five you know it by
heart there's only two ways to propose
amendments I don't have a lot of faith
that Congress will propose
term limits on themselves by the
two-thirds needed I think we all can
agree on that
that is why we are seeking to have you
the state legislatures do it to them
without their consent that is the beauty
of the article 5 convention
the framers in their wisdom understood
that the states would need a check
against a unresponsive federal
government
the American people are sick and tired
of the unresponsive Congress that we
have
the polling the approval rating of
Congress has been below 20 percent for
decades and yet the re-election rate is
over 95 percent
now I'm from Maine I would not waste a
dime in a one-star hotel for an evening
in Concord why are we settling for a
permanent less than a one-star Congress
enough is enough
Washington DC is broken
now term limits is not the Silver Bullet
but it is a good star in the right
direction
the people that control what's happening
to our lives
have been in Congress for decades
yes we send some good people down there
but you all know how the system works
they go down with good intentions
and they get trapped
I like to reference the Borg from Star
Trek they get assimilated into that Borg
and they become part of the problem
now we need to help them out
we need to break the structure up
we cannot change it at The Ballot Box we
can't vote for this now
Court won't let us
it is up to you
it is up to you and what the framers
gave you the power under article 5.
now a little bit more history
since 1789
Congress has not proposed now let me
back up we have 27 amendments to the U.S
Constitution
Congress has proposed 33 so that means
six were never ratified
but they have introduced over 12
000 amendments to the Constitution
twelve thousand
the last Congress the 117th
they introduced 70 amendments to the U.S
Constitution
this 118th Congress in the first two
weeks of session have introduced 15
amendments to the U.S Constitution under
article 5.
some of these are great amendments
there's several termite amendments
now good ideas don't come from
Washington folks they go into a pile
like my presentation sits there and
collects dust
forever
now the same history since 1789 take a
guess how many amendments the states
that has equal Authority with Congress
to propose amendments take a guess how
many amendments they have introduced
zero
not a single amendment by the state
legislatures have ever been introduced
under article 5.
and we wonder why there's a problem
it is time that the states use the
mechanism now this amendment
the chairman mentioned that we have done
this before we have the 22nd Amendment
of a terminals for that president
you know uh Thomas James Madison wrote a
he sent the Constitution to Thomas
Jefferson after it was adopted he I
think he was in uh France at the time
and Jefferson wrote back to him and said
hey here's what I like about it but
there's two things I hate about it
you did not include a Bill of Rights and
you did not include term limits they
used to call it rotation of office
for the president and for the Senate
now Mr Jefferson
shortly after he got his Bill of Rights
and we finally got term limits on the
president a couple hundred years later
but he was a strong advocate for terms
on the Senate
so my
encouragement to you today is that New
Hampshire
should be leading this charge in in my
presentation I hope you can spend some
time I sent this to you in a PDF
there's a lot of misinformation you're
receiving it's all nonsense
we have such experience with conventions
in New Hampshire has the most experience
of all the states
when it comes to a convention to adopt
either a new Constitution or a
convention to propose amendments
New Hampshire has held 17 such
conventions two to adopt a new
Constitution and 15 to propose
amendments
they have proposed 243 amendments and
adopted 145.
so you are actually using this process
you also using the process every year at
the uniform law commission you appoint
Commissioners who meet with all 50 49
states to Draft Solutions it functions
exactly as an article 5 convention in
fact you have two bills before you this
year that have come out of a Convention
of states
so this is not we know how to do this
we're doing it every single year
in fact this legislature sent delegates
to an official Convention of States
called by the legislature of Arizona in
2017. that convention was called to
Draft rules for an article 5 convention
and I have the pictures of your
delegates who went there from this
legislature and they drafted some great
rules so we have rules
we know how to do this we have the
experience now we just need you to pass
hcr4 so that we can get to the
convention now I want to be a realist
with you and I'll wrap things up Mr
chairman you asked a question about
um
would they put it on themselves term
that's a great question I love it
this this breaks my heart to share with
a committee okay let me tell you why I
want to get to a convention
because an article 5 convention will be
a game changer for our country
it will be a game changer for the states
and for our legislatures because they
will realize now we can make change at
the federal level instead of depending
on Congress to try to do it
but
my Common Sense tells me this
because it's happened in the past
as we get closer
to having this convention in our
convention is the most limited
convention you can call we it only you
can only change the number of terms of
the current senators and members of
house that's it the number
but what's going to happen is this
do you really think they will ever let
us get to a convention to impose
terminals on them of course not
they're going to do what they've done in
the past
they will propose an amendment for term
limits and guess what Mr chairman they
will grandfather themselves so it
doesn't affect any of them
because they would rather protect
themselves
then let you
try to clear house
the next year after ratification of that
Amendment because the states would put
together a much better Amendment than
Congress would put together
but sadly our reality and the truth will
probably be they will do it
but here's my dream
they do that
and the people get fed up and see behind
it and we still get to 34. and we get
our Amendment proposed and we have a
dueling process of two amendments I
think the state Amendment will get
ratified before congresses so with that
I will close I will take any questions I
want to just encourage you to please
vote for
HCS
hcr4 there we go fraternal limits on
Congress thank you
thank you Mr Quinn uh Russell Finney
thank you you said you would take
questions I would love to take there's a
question here yes so
um it's good to see you again I can't
think as you're not thank you for being
here my my question is is uh maybe a
little complicated because
right now in our in our current you know
social and political climate we're
seeing a lot of upheaval and
on this issue specifically but what
we're not mentioning is the the hyper
partisan ideologies that are starting to
to creep in the you know to the body
politic how do we
how do we impose term limits without
talking about the issue of a
partisanship how do we make this a
nonpartisan issue completely so that
we're not voting for parties we're
voting for people and policies because
that's the real issue is that you know
people are are staying in office even
though you know Congress sucks they're
staying in office because their party is
in office how do we change that
well that's the beauty of this this
issue term limits because it's
completely nonpartisan all it provides
is an open seat where anybody can run
for office and what I see about with
term limits
I do see an opportunity for people
outside of the two-party system to
actually win some seats because right
now they can't
the the way the system is rigged is that
97 of corporate Pac money goes to the
incumbents all right the parties on both
sides
any Challenger that tries to run against
incumbent you know what happens to them
they don't last very long they're
usually threatened out during the
primary and this they they keep their
their seats safe what open seat election
does it gives us fair and more
competitive elections only about 20
percent of a congressional districts or
even competitive today because so many
seats are so safe
and we as voters I'm tired of voting for
the same person
cycle after cycle after cycle we I want
choices and when you have an open seat
elections we have more people running
for office we have more people with
different backgrounds participating in
our government that can bring some
new eyes with some fresh ideas don't we
need that in Congress right now some
fresh ideas
same old same old is getting us same old
same old
and that's what terminals will help to
do it will help to address this
this party problem that we seem to have
with the country today on both sides I'm
so sick of it
I hope that answers your question
other questions for Mr Quinn yes
representative O'Neill
thank you
um so I don't disagree with you on many
of the issues that you're reciting about
Congress today I think probably all of
us would
um but my question for you is you know
you mentioned the corporate Pac money
going to incumbents
um I see the bigger problem as the money
and wouldn't you think that this type of
solution to the problem as opposed to
trying to overturn something like
citizens united is going to get at that
problem or is that money just going to
go to the next person they cherry pick
to run for office yeah there's some this
is what's great about term limits term
limits is actually a form of campaign
Finance reform because of that money
that goes the incumbents now when you
have so many new people running
you know I I don't like to discredit
people but we know how Congress works
once they have a legislator down in DC
for a while they become very tight with
the lobbyists the special interest
groups
and I hate to say it but they're kind of
owned
it's just just reality
what this will do is
now when somebody runs for office
that money's not going to flow so easily
because now they they don't know who
they're betting on
and the beauty of this is these
individuals will not be able to stay
there for decades and so it's going to
be just think about this way wave after
wave of new people showing up
in Washington DC election after election
it tends to reduce the amount of money
that's going to protect the incumbents
that is the power of this whole thing
it's a structural change
we also have seen studies where the
spending in Washington is is much less
once they're there typically after their
third term in the house they start that
wallet tends to be much wider
and the spending gets out of control
whereas new people don't spend as much
money because they want to learn where
is this money going they're a little
more responsible with our money
and so when it comes to Financial
fiscal responsibility on both the
election end of it and
government spending term limits will go
a long way to helping get us in the
right direction
thank you
I actually wanted to add on to her Point
what is there any Fail-Safe to where
this process wouldn't just become
corrupt within itself
um I'm just stating due to Citizens
United you know we you don't have to
know where money comes from so say
picking the delegates by each state
um who's to say that the people in
office we're not going to get money
thrown at us or you know things thrown
at us for picking the right delegates to
go
from our state to this convention
it seemed to be a revolving door unless
solving a court problem well the um the
beauty of the article 5 process is now
we're talking about you individuals
and more than likely most of the
delegates that are sent will be state
legislators
and that's
I don't have a fear that the
multi-millionaires will be buying off
people who are just going to spend
probably a week together in a meeting
pass an amendment and send it back out
you know this and the other thing is
that's why you're looking at a delegate
limitation Act as well because there's
going to be consequences
there is also the
The Pledge system of a commission when
you appoint as a legislature they are
legally bound already when you appoint
your delegates let's say New Hampshire
sends seven delegates it's one state one
vote so it doesn't matter how many you
send
they that delegation is bound to their
Commission
and so they can't violate their
commission they can't change anything
that takes place down there they can't
change the subject matter they can only
go and vote on the amendment for term
limits now you can also bind them how
you want them to vote as a legislature
if you don't want tournaments then you
can bind them that way I would not
recommend that if you want to stay in
office for very long because I don't
think your constituents would be very
happy if you prevented term limits in
Congress so
there's a lot of safeguards in regard
and that's one thing that I I tend to
feel I have more faith in people today
I I trust what you folks do
I I believe that we can you're doing it
already with you doing it with the
uniform law commission you're appointing
people they're coming back with
solutions that they
thought of drafted debated worked on and
they're coming back and they're
presenting them to you
so they're not corrupted by anything
like that and this is state law it's a
lot easier to get one state law passed
than it is an amendment to the US
Constitution that requires three
quarters of the state legislatures or or
three quarters of the conventions so if
there's going to be a lot of corruption
it'd be more of a microcosm convention
process
thank you
other questions for Mr Quinn
sing on thank you for your testimony for
being here
a personal note I don't know how any of
these measures will play out obviously
we're early in the process but I think
it's healthy
I think people watching in
following this will inevitably learn
something about our processes and our
history and our government and so that
is just a plus I think
um that's is there anyone else who wants
to speak to this measure uh yes sir uh
Mr brandino
foreign
we have a measure in front of us
um but as you were following up on my
point about understanding Civics
um who did you want to have take a
minute or two to clarify that different
could you take uh one to two minutes
because that that is a good question for
whoever's listening or watching to
clarify the difference between a con car
and a constitutional convention can you
do that in a minute or so yes I can and
uh all this information is in the PDF I
sent the committee members
the terminology con con is kind of a
derogatory phrase it means
Constitutional Convention and the
opponents to an article 5 convention in
Article 5 conventions a convention for
proposing amendments that the states
apply for
a constitutional a true Constitutional
Convention
can is called to adopt a new
constitution completely different
entities in fact James Madison writes
about the two in federals 85 if you're
watching read federals 85 Alexander
Hamilton's explains the differences
a constitutional convention requires
unanimous consent to call it requires
unanimous consent to pass in the
convention and is unanimous consent to
ratify to the for the states that will
be bound to it and Article 5 takes
two-thirds to call a simple majority to
pass and three quarters to ratify and it
binds all 50 states completely different
James Madison uh addresses this in his
letter to George Turbeville which your
the opponents are sending you a quote by
Madison that he feared he trembled at a
second convention if you read the letter
he explains the two differences of these
conventions he did not fear an article 5
convention what he feared at that time
was redoing what he had just got done
and read making an entirely new
Constitution that is what he was
trembling about he didn't want to go
through that again because they just
could they couldn't do any better than
what they did
he's not referring to an article 5
convention
thank you for that quick civics lesson
that'll be on YouTube Forever for
whoever watches these things and uh is
an old Civics teacher I appreciate you
taking that extra minute any other
comments on this or anyone wish to speak
to this measure
not saying any we will close this
hearing and in three minutes we're due
to take up another uh measure which is
hcr5 I do want to say uh to the members
that I have spoken with and communicated
with the ranking member and we may have
a break depending upon how long this
next measure takes with 45 minutes
alloted to it if we don't use all that
time we may try to exec one or two bills
that uh the ranking member and I have uh
have flagged is some measures that we
may be able to exec so just uh in FYI I
know not everybody can stay here but if
we have a quorum standby we may try to
exec a couple bills before we finish
uh this afternoon
okay uh inform let me ask if the prime
sponsor for hcr5 that would be
uh representative Kaplan is
representative Kaplan
in the house I I'm not seeing a whole
lot of people here
and representative cat so anyone here uh
this measure has several co-sponsors
that would be
hcr5
which urges appropriate legal action
against multinational fossil fuel
companies for harms incurred from
disinformation campaigns about the
effects of fossil fuel combustion
uh rest of Wallace offered to introduce
that I'm going to say no
at this time
president Shirley do you uh no problem
introducing
hr7 with the prime sponsors also yeah
and you'd already you'd already
mentioned okay sure
uh if if you would yeah that way you can
be seen on YouTube better yeah
okay
welcome uh representative Kaplan yes yes
all right are we honest uh
representative Kaplan um if you can hang
on just a minute or two we're
following the rules here and we don't
want to start early because
that is a is a rule but uh my watch is
almost uh 2 30.
and we have a couple folks signing in so
give us just another minute or so sure
okay I have uh 14 30 2 30 and uh welcome
to representative Kaplan who is the
Prime sponsor for hcr5 uh welcome and uh
looking forward to hearing your
introduction okay thank you chair and
and uh thank you members of the
committee
I know you all would agree that uh
thankfully we live in a nation under the
rule of law designed to protect the
interests of individuals and of our
institutions and Society
one of the basic tenets of the law from
Hammurabi down to English common law and
the drafting of our constitution
is that injured parties have the right
to seek redress of their Grievances and
the damages which have been inflicted
upon them by the actions of others
under the capitalist system we enjoy
that includes the right to redress from
the actions of private corporations in
cases when they have operated under the
cloak of corporate anonymity to defraud
and perpetrate crimes against an
unwitting public
cases brought against corporations for
fraudulent actions that result in
Damages are difficult and often drawn
out
Affairs that take place and culminate
only after a long period of years
Corporation is the most powerful
especially may have immense powers of
purse and influence to wield when they
are under public scrutiny
for example the so-called Master
settlement agreement in favor of the
attorney's general of 46 States against
the four largest tobacco companies in
1998 was a product of a legal process
that began in the 1950s when reports
began to be published linking tobacco
use to cancer
and individual acquaintance began
unsuccessfully to bring suits in the
courts against the tobacco industry the
efforts of the tobacco industry to
defend against these actions included
casting doubt on the science
which I concluded without a doubt that
the use of tobacco was linked to
increased prevalence of lung and heart
damage
more recently New Hampshire was the
beneficiary in 2017 of a settlement
between
the U.S Department of Justice and
Volkswagen where 15 billion dollars for
knowingly violating the Clean Air Act by
placing software designed to cheat on
emissions let tests in their automobiles
this bill hdr5 considers the actions of
major fossil fuel companies in enacting
a campaign of disinformation over the
last 30 years lying about the
destabiling globally catastrophic
results of the use of their products on
the climate system we have depended on
for all of human history
when they knew the truth was the exact
opposite of what their public
pronouncements and the pronouncements of
the institutions they funded were saying
and are still saying today
the science of climate change is not new
in 1859 the Irish physicist John Tyndall
first wrote about the greenhouse effect
which underpins the science of climate
change namely the way in which so-called
greenhouse gases
including carbon dioxide trap heat in
the Earth's atmosphere in just the way a
pane of glass operates in a greenhouse
or in your living room window if it
faces South
by trapping the heat of the Sun
Dr James Hansen of NASA's Goddard
Institute first brought the problems
associated with human production of
greenhouse gases to public attention in
the U.S when testifying before the
senate in 1988 Hanson reported that he
was 99 certain
that the climate was warmer than ever
measured to be as a result of humans
pumping greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere and the likelihood of extreme
weather was steadily increasing due to
human behavior
the conclusions of Dr Hansen enjoyed
immediate bipartisan support
under pressure from the Reagan
Administration the World Meteorological
association the United Nations program
on the environment created the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change ipcc in 1988 to function as a
research and advisory body to the
world's governments
since then ipcc scientists funded by the
world's governments have issued 10 major
reports
detailing with increasing gravity and
alarm the risks associated with
emissions of greenhouse gases primarily
and overwhelmingly due to the use of
fossil fuels
the most recent report in 2021 stated it
is unequivocal that human influence has
warmed the atmosphere ocean and land
widespread and rapid changes in the
atmosphere ocean cryosphere and
biosphere have occurred and human
influence has warmed the climate at a
rate that is unprecedented in at least
the last two thousand years
long before Dr Hansen testified to the
Senate we now know due to investigative
journalism that scientists hired by the
oil industry in the 1970s had already
drawn similar conclusions and heeding
the warning of their own scientists oil
companies set to work figuring out what
impact their products were having
on the atmosphere the oceans and the
world's climate system
but instead of coming clean and agreeing
with Dr Hansen in 1988 that there was a
problem that needed fixing the major oil
companies pivoted to a campaign of
denial and doubt about the science
protecting their Investments and their
shareholders instead of doing what they
could to mitigate what they knew to be a
possibly existential threat on a
planetary scale if nothing was done to
curb the combustion of oil and gas
the impacts of this influence campaign
have been astoundingly successful for
the oil companies but tragic for the
rest of us
while the ipcc and the consensus of
Sciences around the world sounded the
alarm
for 30 years the fossil fuel companies
carried out a denial deception and
propaganda campaign
so persuasive that to this day members
of our political establishment failed to
fully accept
climate science and in the halls of our
own State House leaders can be found
right now who will recite fossil fuel
propaganda
casting doubt on the need to drastically
curb fossil fuel dependence in order to
avoid extreme climate scenarios
under the spell of the sophisticated
public relations effort instead of
taking immediate action
we have delayed joining the fight
against climate change and the costs
associated with doing nothing have
multiplied exponentially in that 30-year
period
who will pay these costs
the public and generations to come
what would Justice be in the case of
such an extreme crime
that is the duty of the courts to decide
our duty I suggest if we are to take our
charge seriously of looking out for the
interests of our constituents in the
state is to allow this resolution to go
forward
hdr5s
urges New Hampshire to join Rhode Island
New York Massachusetts Minnesota
Delaware Connecticut New Jersey and the
District of Columbia and seeking legal
redress for the harms caused by the oil
companies fraudulent and costly campaign
to sow doubt Among Us
thank you
thank you representative questions for
the representative
Prime sponsor
seeing none at this time thank you again
we have several folks who would like to
testify the list here all are in support
of the measure
of hcr5
and we will start with uh
Ayla schwernstein if I said that
correctly Isla
from uh from Portland Maine
the Senate Center for climate Integrity
asked for seven minutes yes thank you
uh thank you chairman and thank you all
for for being here my name is Isla
shorenstein and I'm the political
director for our state and local
programs at the center for climate
Integrity we are a National Organization
but I'm not far I live in Portland Maine
and I'm here to testify in support of
Representative kaplan's resolution to
hold fossil fuel companies accountable
for the harm they've knowingly caused so
I just want to be very clear and lay
some background climate change we know
is harmful but it's also really
expensive according to the United States
Environmental Protection Agency New
Hampshire is experiencing earlier
Springs which bring with it much heavier
precipitation
quote heavy rainstorms are more frequent
and summers are hotter and drier sea
level is rising and severe storms cause
floods that damage property and
infrastructure in the coming decades the
changing climate is likely to increase
flooding harm ecosystems and winter
Recreation disrupt farming and increase
some risk to human health which are
include heat related illnesses and
vector-borne disease
this past summer New Hampshire received
roughly half the normal amount of
precipitation throwing the majority of
the state into a rapid onset drought by
August 3rd 65 Community water systems
and six towns or cities had water
restrictions in place and Farmers across
the state were experiencing higher
operational costs due to having diesel
costs for pumping water and much lower
yields so meanwhile the lead story in
the valley times yesterday was about how
climate change is making New Hampshire
Winters more mild and snow free although
we wouldn't know it today but this of
course impacts winter tourism
groundwater supplies and agricultural
cops crops like blueberries you know
it's late January and the majority of
the state is only getting its first
major snowstorm today or last night
um but New Hampshire taxpayers are the
ones that are facing greater and greater
costs to respond to these disruptions
both in terms of reactive measures like
disaster recovery and proactive measures
like resilience and adaptation projects
and since 2004 there have been about
five extreme weather events in New
Hampshire that cost 15 million dollars
in Damages uh primarily due to flooding
and Ice storms so the question that we
can then ask is why should the fossil
fuel industry be made to pay for some of
these costs so there are two reasons
number one uh because of the science it
points us directly to a handful of
specific companies that are to blame for
fueling the climate crisis
and number two because a trove of
internal industry documents that
representative Kaplan mentioned and
other evidence show us that many of
these same companies had first-hand
knowledge about the harms their own
products would cause and then
deliberately lied about what they knew
while selling and marketing these same
products to Consumers
so I'll speak to the science first and
it's important to remember that climate
change didn't just happen on its own
Studies have found that nearly
two-thirds of all greenhouse gas
emissions since the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution can be traced to
just 90 individual companies companies
like Exxon Chevron shell BP Conoco
Phillips and many many more so the
science is crystal clear on this we are
not all equally to blame for the
Emergency that we find ourselves in
but not only did the fossil fuel
industry perpetuate this crisis these
same companies knew about the impact of
burning fossil fuels and they knew this
over 60 years ago
hundreds of internal industry documents
uncovered by journalists and researchers
show that fossil fuel companies like
Exxon knew decades ago that burning
fossil fuels would raise global
temperatures which would then have
disastrous impacts worldwide by the 80s
they were predicting in their own words
globally catastrophic effects
they even made specific projections
about the east coast in a 1982 memo
Exxon projected flooding up and down the
Eastern Seaboard as New Hampshire
Seacoast now experiences a 1988 shell
memo details a number of projected
climate impacts including sea level rise
local losses of food sources due to
rising ocean temperatures natural
resource damage because of ocean
acidification destruction of farmland
and costly adaptations to the buildings
in which people live and work often in
the form of extra air conditioning
so just last week uh the first ever
peer-reviewed study of exxon's internal
climate projections was released showing
that company scientists predicted the
future rate of global warming with
startling accuracy even as their
Executives publicly so doubt about the
climate science
company Executives understood that
addressing climate change meant limiting
carbon emissions which would hurt the
industry's bottom line so the oil and
gas companies took a page from the big
tobacco Playbook like the tobacco
companies that denied their products
cause cancer and addiction oil and gas
companies spread disinformation about
their product's leading role in causing
climate change documents have revealed a
massive coordinated campaign to lie to
the public lawmakers and the media about
the catastrophic impacts they knew their
products would cause the further reveal
how the industry spent millions of
dollars to block climate action over the
last several decades
so in addition to a mountain of internal
company documents Exxon insiders have
gone on the record uh to talk about what
the company knew and what it did with
that knowledge a former scientific
consultant testified under oath before
Congress saying quote Exxon was publicly
promoting views that its own scientists
knew were wrong
the company's top lobbyists admitted
um this in a recorded interview quote
did we aggressively fight against some
of the science yes in 2021 while
testifying under oath before Congress
current Exxon executive CEO Darren woods
and other oil Executives even refused to
pledge to stop spending money on lies
about climate change
yet even as these companies undermine
the science and lied to the public about
the role of fossil fuels in perpetuating
the climate crisis the industry took the
issue seriously enough to protect their
own assets from the from a warming world
as early as the 1970s companies like
Chevron and shell were filing patents
for equipment that would work in a
warming Arctic and raising oil rigs to
account for sea level rise
while the industry's infrastructure may
be very well protected against the harms
caused by climate change communities
across the country and here in New
Hampshire are now facing staggering
costs to adapt to a worsening crisis
so who should be the ones to cover the
cost of climate damages taxpayers and
impacted communities or the companies
that knowingly created and continue to
profit from the climate emergency we are
now facing I for one don't think that
those costs should fall 100 on the backs
of taxpayers it is more than reasonable
for Big Oil to pay their fair share of
the damage they caused
the Attorney General's office has a long
history of holding Bad actors
accountable for the damage they've
caused to the people of New Hampshire
when the tobacco and the opioid
Industries engage in fraudulent
fraudulent and deceptive practices the
Attorney General took action to hold
them accountable for the resulting harms
their actions had caused in recent years
like representative Kaplan mentioned
eight attorneys generals have taken
fossil fuel companies to court to hold
them accountable for the costs of their
climate lies these include the
neighboring states of Vermont
Massachusetts Connecticut and Rhode
Island the plaintiffs in each of these
cases have made the following argument
big oil companies knew they lied and
they should be held accountable
just as tobacco and opioid industries
were held accountable for their fraud
and deception and the resulting harm the
fossil fuel industry must not be allowed
to escape legal liability and pass off
the extraordinary costs of these harms
with impunity
so I urge you I vote I am fate in favor
of this resolution and I support
representative Kaplan thank you so much
thank you Mr Stein would you accept any
questions absolutely
does anyone have any questions go ahead
representative gagne
thank you for taking my question
assuming that all that you've said is
true I'm assuming that it's all true
okay
that would deal with the United States
would deal with the oil companies
fine what do we do with China what do we
do with Russia all those they're
building like one coal plant a day in
China right so what do we do so we're
gonna punish us ourselves but allow the
other ones to do their own their thing
we have a prevailing westerlies it's
going to come across the country so why
should we punish us
without going after the other ones I
appreciate the question thank you and
it's a good one I think that there is a
role for the Judiciary to play and
there's a role for policy and there's a
role for international policy right and
all of these things have to work in
concert with each other I think this
slice of the pie dealing with the
Judiciary is following really classic
um law that has precedent and it's just
making sure that these companies don't
continue to lie and make sure that these
communities that are suffering climate
harms have the resources they need to
survive it
follow-up
follow-up thank you thank you for my
okay I burn oil in my house do you think
that the oil companies if they're
punished and they have to pay fines
don't you think that's going to come
back on to the consumer
so you know I'm not going to buy a Tesla
because I can't afford one and I don't
want any of those
solar panels on my roof I like what I've
got right now I shouldn't have to pay 18
for a gallon of heating oil to heat my
house so how do you answer that
it's also a good question
um I have some good tip about that um so
I would say I would say a couple things
one that the cost is already being
passed on to us right now taxpayers are
being forced to foot billions of dollars
in the bills from the damages uh these
companies cause and these companies
aren't paying a dime of that currently
um but they also receive massive
subsidies and tax breaks from the
government again at the expense of
taxpayers
um
but I think uh probably more directly to
answer your question
um what would it cost our communities
and the state to not take action climate
and adaptation costs they're here
they're only mounting and one way or the
other communities are going to be forced
to pay this bill and the only question
is will they do it alone or with the
help of those most responsible
foreign
thank you
um I agree with you about the issue of
you know of uh subsidies and
in those kind of issues
um
but I think in this country we have a
precedent of
these these big energy corporations they
they treat the Clean Air Act as like a
as you know it's just like a fine how do
we how do we uh
change the law in your guys's view that
strengthening the fine would stop them
from from polluting the water in the air
because currently with paying these
fines that the government is giving them
in the billions of dollars we're not
seeing any changes so what uh what what
kind of action would this HCR
specifically be doing at all
um thank you for that and I am um not a
Clean Air Act expert so I'm gonna try my
best here but um I think with with
regards to uh hdr5 this has to do with
the state and the Attorney General's
office so it's really less of a policy
question and more of you know what is
the what does the what are the tools
that the attorney general has in their
office to make sure that taxpayers are
not on the hook for all of these costs
so I yeah and I think that
um that precedent is out there in the
form of tobacco and opioid cases right
we've seen you know when they lie there
are damages to be sought there
other questions uh representative
Massimo
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um it's two-part first of all is your
testimony available for us I submitted
online yesterday okay thank you
one thing is you referred to a couple of
court cases that other New England
states had brought forward regarding
this what were the outcomes so they are
still um in their it's a been a long
process
um let's see I have uh so
there's been a big effort from the
companies themselves to delay these
cases as long as humanly possible
um but they have not had any success in
doing that well they've had some success
in delaying it but they haven't made
these cases go away
um judges unanimous unanimously all over
the country have ruled in favor of the
plaintiffs to allow these cases to
proceed towards trial so they're all at
different stages of litigation the state
of Massachusetts and the municipality of
Honolulu Hawaii have both are in process
of pre-trial Discovery and we you know
hope and expect that some of the more
cases will be headed towards their soon
other questions
thank you so much
Miss yornstein thank you
and I see
both John and Catherine Gage are in the
house over here last year
um
I'm going to call on Catherine first
who asked for three minutes
to speak in support of this resolution
welcome back Catherine
thank you
um I would like to testify in support of
this resolution because I think it's
really important to hold fossil fuel
industry accountable for their decision
to continue to pollute that is harming
all of us and the environment after they
researched several decades ago and
figured out the harm that they were
doing with their products and they chose
to continue anyway and not only are they
causing all the problems we have but
they're also making it very hard to
address the problems because of their
influence in politics
um when I was in eighth or middle school
I learned about a policy called cash
back carbon pricing that would be really
helpful in addressing climate change so
I joined a group to Lobby Congress for
it and I thought that it would be a
great idea so they would
probably get on board and it would pass
sometime soon but it has made very
little progress since then like six
years later and that's because there's
so much fossil fuel industry funding in
Congress in both parties and it's
preventing really meaningful action on
climate change which would be bad for
their business
um so it's really important to hold them
accountable for what they're doing
because they've shown that their top
priority is money not our health and
safety and the environment and
so
I think this resolution would help with
that thank you
thank you Miss Gage questions for the
speaker for the testifier
thanks again thank you
and John Gage
from Windham representing himself asking
for five minutes
foreign
chair I really appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you today
um this is this issue has affected me
personally uh I started losing I started
my science background in college I have
a biology degree I learned about global
warming
40 years ago and figured that the
um the experts would take care of the
problem
uh 10 years ago
about when the Ned pipeline was going to
go through my town I started seeing news
articles that were just wrong about
general science about global warming I I
knew greenhouse gases from fossil fuels
was climate pollution I knew that there
was some kind of problem but I didn't
know much about it I did a lot of
research
about the science of global warming and
about why we hadn't solved yet this is a
book by noima reskis called merchants of
doubt
10 years ago she did a study she's a
Harvard researcher why the public was so
out of line with the science the
scientists were 97 percent confident
that human activities were causing
global warming but the public was 50 and
why was that and it was because of this
disinformation campaign that you heard
about
um there was Pulitzer Prize winning
investigative journalism from inside
climate news and the Los Angeles Times
which further exposed what the fossil
fuel industry knew in the 70s about
global warming from their pollution and
how accurate that has turned out today
in terms of the emissions rise rise of
concentration of CO2 and what we see in
the atmosphere and the rise of
temperatures
um
you know this is frustrating because I
left my job four years ago at Oracle
Corporation to volunteer full-time uh as
my daughter said to help create the
political will to enable Congress to
pass effective and Equitable legislation
so you asked about what what about China
representative gagne it's a simple
policy economists they're almost
universally in support of to address
your concern and many other concerns
and a year ago to this day we testified
against H.R 17 which was a resolution
against the carbon tax
but economists say
we put a tax on pollution in our own
economy by charging the polluting
Industries the fossil fuel producers
rebate all the money back to households
each month in an equal per capita
dividend to protect purchasing power
that will let most people come out ahead
financially more money each month in
their carbon dividend than their pain
and total higher prices
but a price on pollution is the most
cost effective way to reduce it so the
fossil fuel industry does not want a
price on carbon what about China well as
our carbon price Rises and fossil fuels
get more expensive manufacturers are
going to be paying higher energy prices
this is going to cause our manufacturers
to go out of out of the country to to be
able to produce on cheaper energy unless
we use border carbon adjustments which
is the third part of the solution we can
charge our carbon fion imports from free
polluting countries and rebate our
exporters so they can compete on a Level
Playing Field in both markets this will
make U.S manufacturers more competitive
against developing countries this will
help us be more competitive right now
today
Europe and other countries are already
doing this the European Union's price is
80 a ton and they're going to use border
carbon adjustments
um on papers during this year and for
real in three more years they're going
to start charging our exporters our
carbon price when we sell into the EU
Market
um Canada's using carbon fee and
dividend and they're watching the EU
will probably join the carbon Club we're
going to start paying more and more for
our carbon pollution
um we testified on against the
resolution that I don't think came from
within our state
so the fossil fuel industry money is
smart it's not directly
um
visible on what the doubt and
misinformation that our society is
receiving there's an intermediary group
of organizations front groups that take
fossil fuel money
and then create the propaganda and the
talking points and the talking heads and
some of these groups are producing
material that our legislature is
receiving they're American for
Prosperity Heartland Institute Alec
um in the testimony last year of H.R 17
the the sponsors of the bill said they
had been to conferences of these groups
and they came back with information
about climate change that was completely
wrong
now we have a climate scientist in our
state
um the the booklets that I handed out is
the fourth National Climate assessment
this is the best information about
climate change from our federal
government organizations NASA and no
other department of energy Department of
Defense
we should not be listening to the
information from front groups paid by
fossil fuel industries that are trying
to delay action on behalf of the fossil
fuel polluters we should be listening to
our scientists here at nhdes
um Dr Mary stampone
and the national uh the U.S Global
change research program this is what we
know through science
um and we need to
see that we're being tricked by
out-of-state polluter influence
um
these groups Market themselves as
conservative value organizations and
they do advocate for strong conservative
values in many things but that doesn't
make them right about everything and so
if they write about 80 percent of what
they do but the bottom 20 is to lie and
mislead about the pollution from fossil
fuels we don't have to believe that part
of the messages that they spread
uh so I strongly support this resolution
uh we need to hold the guilty parties
accountable for for frauding the the
public and delaying action to address
their pollution for four decades
um this doesn't have to cost raise the
cost of energy we can take away their
license to advertise we can take
um away some of the ill-gotten gains
from some of the leaders I recommend
carbon fee and dividend with border
adjustments to take care of the problem
reducing emissions and addressing
external pollution from countries like
China
thank you
thank you Mr Gage questions uh
representative gagne
thank you Mr chairman
I'm assuming for
thinking you are not really high on
fossil fuels is that correct
uh I use them every day I've got a like
two cars that burn gasoline I've got an
oil furnace I'm not big on global
warming because I understand the science
it poses a extremely serious threat to
me and an even bigger threat to my
daughter and future generations and
we're paying for the the costs of the
pollution all over the place and I
resent the fact that the polluting
industry has tricked so many people that
we can't address their pollution problem
uh and we're all using polluting energy
because we haven't been able to make the
policy changes necessary to transition
to clean energy
follow up follow up
so that what you said at the end just
led me to this to my other question if
we could get rid of fossils fossil fuels
look I grew up in from Canada burning
coal okay we burned coal and wood
if there was an alternate method
and other than just electric okay in the
solar panels
would you be in favor of exploring
nuclear power sure which burns its clean
except for the for the waste but you can
bury that thousands of feet down yeah
and a fourth generation looks like you
can use some of the ways to produce more
power and then the waste from that has a
much shorter Half-Life I'm in favor of
of an efficient energy Market
I think trying to pick the solutions and
using government to you know reward some
things and and not others is the wrong
approach
um there's an economist statement in
favor of carbon fee and dividend with
border adjustments supported by over 3
600 U.S economists including two dozen
from Dartmouth and UNH
um and they say what we need is an
efficient energy market so we can
Unleash the Power of the market to
provide the solutions for us we're not
going to get off of fossil fuels in a
decade but we can correct the failure of
the market to account for the costs of
using fossil fuels in their price in a
way that protects U.S businesses and
household purchasing power and holds
other countries accountable if we do
that the solutions that we need will
arise through our free market Innovation
and investment will happen and it's the
fastest most cost effective way to
transition off of fossil fuels I can't
tell you what the winners will be I
suspect nuclear will be a good firm
power solution but it's expensive so it
won't be every it won't be all the
solutions it will be offshore wind there
will be geothermal there will be solar
but let's let them compete on a Level
Playing Field right now that subsidy
that we're giving the fossil fuel
industry by letting them have free
pollution makes their
products the most competitive in the
market but that's only because we're
subsidizing their businesses by giving
them a free write-off of all their
pollution costs
I have one more sir one more follow-up
thank you
you are also aware that the solar panels
and the wind power industries are also
being subsidized by the government right
by our taxes yeah I think the total
subsidy for clean energy is dwarfed by
both the direct explicit subsidies that
we give the fossil fuel industry like
oil depletion allowances and land lease
deals but also the the implicit costs
that we're paying from the damages of
the global warming that results from the
pollution from the fossil fuel industry
which the IMF says is 5.9 trillion
dollars globally a year
seven thousand dollars per Tesla
uh Russell Finney thank you Mr chair
um I'm on the epa's uh site here and um
they do say through domestic and
international action the ozone layer is
healing it should fully recover by 2065.
uh you'd agree that through the
um I guess the social implication that
you know EVS are the the next
alternative to to
um you know to gas vehicles uh that
we've already seen a lot of those
pre-market changes that have been kind
of forced upon is probably Autumn you
know by the uh the makers of all of our
cars but also by federal pressure to to
change their product from gasoline to
EVs and
um my other question I had a two-part
was would you also agree that there's
been a bit of information campaign about
the nuclear energy being not safe and
effective as it actually is and the
waste produced would only fill up about
half the room that we're in right now
correct
um I don't know exactly about nuclear
waste I know there's
um about nine eight million people die a
year from the pollution from fossil
fuels around the world and very few from
uh the results of using nuclear so
nuclear is a much more safe fuel than
fossil fuels as far as the Montreal
protocol that you mentioned
um represent President Reagan uh LED
that with George Schultz as his
secretary of state an international
agreement to address
CFCs chlorofluorocarbons which was in
aerosols and other refrigerants
um which were when they released into
the atmosphere were destroying ozone in
the stratosphere the ozone layer
protects us from UV rays
um that hole was real uh and the reason
that it stopped expanding was because of
the Montreal protocol the federal
government joined with every other
country in the world uh to agree to stop
using CFCs and that's why you don't hear
about the ozone problem anymore because
we joined a treaty and we addressed that
pollution problem now unfortunately the
replacement for CFCs is hfcs
hydrofluorocarbons that turns out to be
an extremely powerful greenhouse gas so
we've replaced our refrigerants which
hfcs and now we find that hfcs are a
significant part of the climate
pollution problem but the U.S Senate
just ratified the Kigali Amendment to
the Montreal protocol
21 Republicans and about 47 or so
Democrats you needed two-thirds vote to
pass to amend to join a treaty
um the Senate passed this resolution to
address hfc climate pollution why did
they do that because U.S businesses are
actually technical they're leading in
the technology for The Replacements of
hfcs in refrigerants so this is a
competitive Advantage for the us we want
the rest of the world to stop using hfcs
because
by the end of the century if we didn't
do anything that would be worth about
0.5 degrees Celsius of warming just from
hfcs so we've taken care of that problem
and we've made U.S businesses more
competitive against China which is the
main competitor in the in refrigerants
so
we can do the same thing with carbon
dioxide
take a look just think about
if you charge every country the same
amount for carbon pollution the cleaner
countries the cleaner producing
countries will pay less of a charge than
the dirtier polluting countries so the
EU has got a high carbon price they're
going to do c-bam starting on paper this
year but for real in 2026 we will our
manufacturers who export into the EU
will have to pay their carbon price when
we put our Goods energy intensive Goods
into the EU Marketplace
you know that's going to make our Goods
more expensive right
um China is going to have to do the same
thing they're going to pay three times
as much of a carbon price on their
products as we are in India is going to
have to pay four times as much carbon
price to export goods into the EU
Marketplace this is a competitive
advantage that businesses will enjoy
when we price carbon here and use border
adjustments to help push it around the
world
follow up
just one more follow-up sorry one more
follow-up
um it seems it seems more
realistic excuse me
um that a lot of these you know the
major corporations who would contribute
to this issue like Exxon you know and
and you know Chevron for instance
there's they're so big and powerful that
these carbon taxes would be treated as a
fine these I I'm not convinced or I
don't see a strong argument in favor of
a higher tax that would actually solve a
problem they would you know
they would see the fine as just another
payment that they have to make but they
wouldn't make any you know you know
systemic changes so is this HCR asking
the federal government to take a
stronger step towards I guess
uh stopping the Monopoly in the market
by making them make changes because uh
that's not the federal government's
roles to regulate you know no this
resolution is simply
um to go through a legal
um form to hold them accountable for the
fraud that they are still today part of
um they're preventing policy changes
that are needed to reduce pollution
by funding organizations that produce
misinformation and control policies and
politics what we're trying to do with HR
hcr5 is basically like what we did with
the tobacco industry when it got exposed
that they knew nicotine was addictive
and that smoking caused cancer
um they kept saying that they didn't
know until papers got released that
proved they did and then we held them
accountable and so this is the same kind
of thing hdr5 simply says look we know
we we have proof that the fossil fuel
industry knew their carbon emissions
were pollution four decades ago
um we know they fund disinformation
campaigns and are manipulating us to
delay acting on their pollution
um we need to hold them accountable this
is you know racketeering this is
um this is not something that we want
going on in capitalism it gives
capitalism a really bad name
other questions represent Manion
so uh on on the subject of the I know
we're getting into the weeds it's not
about this bill but about the um the
carbon tariffs across so like the you
say the companies would end up paying it
but it's actually the consumer that
would end up paying it is that not right
uh economists look at it there's a pass
through so somewhere between 70 and 100
of the fee that you charge a fossil fuel
producer will get reflected in the costs
of the fuels that they sell which is why
what you do with that money that you
collect is so important if you put it
into a carbon trust and rebate it in
equal shares back to all households each
month
um most families will end up with more
carbon cash back than the total that
they pay multiple Studies have shown and
Canada is doing this today about 80
percent of Canadians are coming out
ahead so this is a beneficial way to put
a price on carbon now the government
could spend the money they could pay
down debt they could use it for other
things you know we advocate for carving
cash back because we need the political
popularity of it and it also helps
families and it supports getting high
carbon price that we need so a ton of
coal produces about three tons of carbon
dioxide gas
but the amount of energy you get from a
ton of coal is less than what you get
from a ton of natural gas
and solar and wind you may have to use
fossil fuels to produce the equipment
until we switch everything but they
produce very little so if you put the
price on the pollution the market gets
to pick the winners and losers based on
what is the cheapest and that's why it's
so efficient nobody's picking winners
and losers You're simply saying let's
correct this market failure by pricing
pollution and let the market decide what
the winners are
other questions
see number before I let you go uh Mr
Gage let me throw something on at you
real quick we have one more speaker
um we have Ice Age let me set this up a
little bit if you feel indulge me we
have ice ages uh historically the four
major ice ages including one not that
long ago so climate is cyclical I
obviously we have ice ages from time to
time then it gets warmer now the
man-made part of it this is what we're
wrestling with so but my the question
I'm going to pause it to you uh has to
do you mentioned several times global
warming you just mentioned a half
Celsius increased uh in 1816 this is
even before me or representative
shirtliff around he he may probably cold
winter yes okay
exactly okay so representative Sterling
for members knows where I'm going with
this there was a huge volcanic eruption
in Indonesia uh cloud of the skies and
is representative just pointed out it
snowed every month and for a couple
years it was uh terribly cold here in
fact that's why so many people get the
heck out if I can say that they got the
heck out of New Hampshire because they
couldn't farm and they just went that's
historical fact and so a Krakatoa type
uh ex seismic cataclysmic volcanic
disruption that or asteroids have caused
these ice ages my question to you is
given that these major seismic
cataclysmic volcanic disruptions that
will darken the sky and lower the
temperatures probably will happen again
if it's true and I let's say everything
you say is absolutely true the global
warming that you mentioned is happening
is it possible that this global warming
could mitigate the next uh
uh traumatic uh volcanic uh disruption
in in help us is is that possible
um so we are we were in an a stage with
for the last two million or so years
um there's a glacial period of where
this part of the world gets covered with
ice and that lasts about 90 000 years
and then there's an interglacial period
of warming which lasts five or ten
thousand years so we've been in this
cycle for millions of years
um
so uh a couple years doesn't mean you're
in an ice age
um the science of what the forcings are
on the Earth's energy balance to
determine temperature is really
interesting
um when a giant volcano blows up uh it
produces amount enormous amounts of
aerosols which shade the Earth and cause
cooling for a couple years but then the
particles drop back out of the
atmosphere and the temperature goes back
up we have natural variability all the
time but we're not talking about that
when we talk about climate you know
that's weather we had a couple years of
cold weather the the climate is on a
30-year time scale like what was the
average of our weather for the last 30
years so that's what we're talking about
what's warming
um
we know the world is warming because of
our pollution
um we could get hit by an asteroid or a
giant volcano could erupt and change our
weather for a couple years but after a
couple years we'll get back to the
energy we're not in an energy balance
where we have an energy imbalance
because we've been adding so many
greenhouse gases to the air and carbon
dioxide stays up there for hundreds or
thousands of years we are going to get
back to this temperature in a couple
years because the Earth you know comes
back to an equilibrium
kind of scientists say we're going to
warm for another two or three decades
we're gonna we've wormed since 1900
about one degree Celsius globally this
is taking an enormous amount of energy
it's like something like 400 000
um Hiroshima size atomic bombs worth of
energy every day is getting added to
that your system because of our
greenhouse gases it's warming the oceans
it's warming the land
um this is a long-term Trend and so when
we stop polluting it's not going to get
back to normal we're going to warm for
another two or three decades rapidly
like we are now and then it's going to
start to you know level off but we can't
stop polluting completely immediately we
we're going to need fossil fuels for
decades so what we need to do is come up
with targets to reduce emissions by that
will let us meet you know kind of Max
temperature goals that's where 50
emission reductions by 2030 and fit and
Net Zero by 2050 come from that would
let us hold warming to one and a half
degrees which is a half degrees warmer
than we have right now but it's a much
safer future than if we go for another
20 or 30 years before we get serious and
and finally reduce our carbon emissions
thank you for that other questions
seeing none uh thank you Mr Gates I
think we got our money's worth out of
you thank you for your time and
obviously you've spent a lot of time on
this subject uh my last card here is for
Richard
Osman is Richard Richard is here thank
you Richard
sorry
foreign
thank you for your patience my name is
Dominic Osmond I live in Manchester and
I am here representing 350 New Hampshire
which is a state-based climate Justice
organization I am also a registered
lobbyist on behalf of 350 New Hampshire
this is my first public testimony and
I'm pretty sure I'm supposed to tell you
all that
um so forgive me for any mistakes first
of all I would just like to thank this
committee for your time in hearing this
incredibly important bill
foreign
I strongly encourage this community to
vote in favor of house concurrent
resolution 5 to call on New Hampshire's
governor and attorney general to step up
for granted seders and pursue legal
action against the companies that have
profited off the pollution of our
atmosphere
fossil fuel energy companies such as
Exxon Mobil shell Chevron and countless
others have spent decades denying the
effects of burning fossil fuels and the
consequences of global climate change
that the burning of these fossil fuels
has and will create
as was mentioned by previous speakers as
early as the 1970s there was a
scientific consensus that that emitting
CO2 in the atmosphere would both
increase global temperatures and also
create uh unmitigated uh climate climate
change that we cannot fully predict
the fact that CO2 when emitted into the
atmosphere creates warming through a
greenhouse effect has been documented
and known since as early as the 19th
century right after the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution of which the
consequences we are currently dealing
with
through the through the release of
internal emails and reports it has been
made public that not only did fossil
fuel companies in the 70s and 80s know
that the
results of their business practices were
creating significant significant global
warming and climate change but despite
this they worked to cover cover up the
consequences of their business practices
over the last 30 and 40 years they've
spent billions of dollars hiring
lobbyists funding think tanks founding
industry groups all to work to deny the
mounting pile of evidence that we need
to stop burning fossil fuels in order to
avert climate
climate catastrophe
through those released documents and
emails we knew that their own internal
experts and scientists were creating
prediction models and and reports that
were basically in line with the results
being produced by the scientists who
were on the outside calling for
reductions in burning fossil fuels so
essentially they knew what they were
doing and they proceeded to lie anyway
that is also revealed in the in the
internal documents they came forward
like with the the tobacco companies they
knew what they were doing they were
intentionally lying and misleading the
public governments and regulatory
agencies in the service of their of
their profits
the perpetrators of this massive public
fraud and cover-up are some of the
biggest and most profitable companies in
America and around the world
they're worth trillions of dollars and
have tens of billions uh in profit every
year they have become unimaginably
wealthy and Powerful off the backs of
the regular people both in this state in
this country and around the world that
they have lied to and misled
with every uh passing with every passing
summer with every mild winter it becomes
more and more obvious that we are living
in a climate crisis there are once New
Generation floods that happen numerous
times throughout living memory there are
winters in which there isn't a
significant snowstorm until mid-January
there are summer just just this summer
we we set a state record for the hottest
day of the year we can we are we seeing
and living through the results of this
climate change and as we as we do know
that these are these effects are only
going to continue and accelerate in
their intensity
this is why it is crucial for this state
government for our attorney general to
join with the Coalition of other states
Attorneys General to go after to uh to
go after these companies not only for
you know punitive uh recompensation but
to also take the money that they have
the the unimaginable amounts of money
that they have raised and and made off
of this this public fraud and to take it
back to recoup some of those those
profits to use them to do the things
that we are going to need to in the next
in the coming decades to deal with the
climate crisis
although this will be a crisis of
massive Glo and Global proportions there
are solutions there are things that can
be done to protect people and strengthen
communities making investments in
systems and in infrastructure will
dampen the most harmful impacts and we
can choose to protect those who will not
be able to protect themselves which we
absolutely need to do because that will
be all of us
I I won't go into any any of the facts
that I have prepared because my the
previous speakers have done a much
better job of laying out the scientific
and you know technical reasons for this
the the need for this bill so I'll just
tell a little bit of a personal story to
conclude my comments my father's
birthday is coming up in a couple of
weeks and I mentioned that uh because
you'll be turning 54. so he was born in
1969 which means he was a young teenager
during the early and mid 80s when the
decisions by these fossil fuel companies
to perpetrate this massive public fraud
was being made and right now my youngest
brother is 16 years old which means that
this this cover-up has been going on for
an entire generation in the time that it
take my father to grow up to to to go to
college to start a business to raise a
family
all of this has been done in that time
and I really don't want to in another 30
or 40 years look back and say that that
we're also we were still unable to to do
anything about it to to fix the problems
that have been caused by fossil fuel
companies and to to do something about
it so to conclude my statement I would
like to again strongly encourage this
committee to vote in favor of this
legislation and uh thank you I am done
would you take any questions if they're
already gladly
good practice for a few budding
lobbyists representative gagne
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question actually it's more of
a comment excellent presentation thank
you very much representative uh you're
what school are you going to or did you
go what high school
I I'm actually from Illinois so you
might not have heard of my high school
oh okay I'm class of central of 63 so
your father was born a couple years
later and I graduated from a high school
yeah no my my father went to went to
school just like I did in in Central
Illinois okay good job by the way thank
you very much
other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else here who'd like to
speak on this measure
and not saying anything I will
close this here and we have one more
hearing uh coming up at 3 30 in just a
couple minutes as I said before uh I've
communicated with the ranking member and
we've identified a couple measures that
we think we can execially uh very
quickly well we have a quorum so before
you we'll have in the prime sponsor for
the final resolution is not here and I
believe we're upside if you're going to
introduce it
so representative shirtleff in just a
moment we'll introduce the final measure
of the day and then we'll see how much
comment there is on that and then again
if if uh if you wouldn't mind standing
for just a very brief time I think we
can exact uh two measures very quickly
that we seem to have consensus on get
them on the consent calendar and then
we'll we'll be done
oh I was looking at 3 30. okay uh yes so
introducing the final measure which is
HR uh 17.
um
HR 7 thank you Mr Vice here
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Steve sure at lip and I represent Ward
one of Concord the village of Penacook
Merrimack District 15. uh the prime
sponsor of the bill representative
Atherton is in here with us today so
it's a courtesy to the member I would
introduce to this committee house
resolution 7 calling for the federal
government to preserve or protect
Medicare and Social Security uh without
uh cuts of benefits thank you enough
will go my 30-minute speech thank you Mr
chairman
apparently there will be there will be
no questions taken at this time
does anyone else wish to speak to this
measure hr7
I have a question a question
representative the chair
um because we don't have anybody to to
testify in favor of the bill could we
move it to another day
uh actually we have opened the hearing
on this I I could recess this and come
back to it
um that is an option is that something
you would like to see happen
personally yeah I want to hear someone
you know present an argument for this
bill
oh
that's a call that I can make I believe
and so uh because you would like to have
some and I think that's a fair comment
and a fair request and as the prime is
not here I'm going to suspend this
hearing and we will pick it up uh we
have three more days we'll pick up uh
the sharing uh we'll reschedule the rest
of it at a future time
thank you Mr chair so that is that
December so we've suspended or recessed
this hearing so we are done with it for
today
um at this time then uh I'm looking for
a motion
um on
hb206 that's the first measure we heard
today on including space force in
various definitions of the Armed Forces
uh Madam clerk quick point
certain
so we want to pick a date
okay Madam clerk points out the need to
recess to a date certain which which I
believe is is correct protocol
we will be uh convening next
um Friday a week from today the 27th uh
we'll be in this room in the morning and
then we will be at uh
reps Hall in the afternoon would I what
I'm going to do is because we will be
meeting on the third February 3rd for
our last four measures I'm going to ask
the uh
the
Clerk of the the house clerk to add this
measure to the four that we'll be
hearing in the third and we'll plan to
do it that day in fact uh Madam clerk if
you wouldn't mind following up with
Karen on that one and just add that one
to the uh the last day and the third
um and are you prepared do you have to
to do it the exact with the role and
that type of thing okay so we are
looking for a uh emotion on
HB 206
representative massamila
and your motion
I would like to make a motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 206. we have a we
have a motion of ought to pass OTP on HB
206 and representative gagne was that
you that seconded it we have a motion in
a second to OTP hb206 which we heard
this morning would you like to speak to
your motion very simply if the agent in
General's office supports it and also
the sdac I think that we should go along
with that
thank you representative would anyone
else like to speak to the to the to the
measure
representative just a good idea all
around to try to I know I I spoke to uh
the two Colonels retired Colonels
outside there and
um
the boys are tired it's with the people
boys
the enlistees are tired
and
they're leaving and they can't meet
their uh quotas or no
space force Oh wrong one okay
uh well it's it's part of the military
so it should be included
on its own just like the the air air
force was from the Army Air corps it
became the Air Force and this
it's like a Marine Corps as part of the
Navy Department there
it's not the same thing it's under the
Navy Department it's it's not
necessarily part of the Navy department
but uh the point was made earlier the
point is is that sure I should have kept
my mouth shut uh
thank you representative any would it
uh negative on the amendment
any other comments on the motion
seeing on Madam clerk if you would uh re
read the role
yes
thank you
foreign
yes
sure yes
Mr chairman I recommend that goes on the
consent calendar unless represent Finney
uh prefers that it doesn't
um if I could just speak to my to my
vote I only said no because I wasn't
here for the for the testimony so I
can't say yes if I didn't hear anything
about it I apologize for that
can I do that no if you're present you
must vote yeah okay okay before we close
uh you do you do have an opportunity to
check you can stay in your your Vote or
change it but we have an option right
now before we close to do that so it's
up to you
okay
um
this isn't like establishing a space for
us it's just saying it just includes it
oh okay I I'm sorry I missed this is why
I needed to be here I'm sorry
I could just share my perspective
because I'm not a military person I'm an
outsider so I have an outside
perspective but one of the things that
struck me in the testimony this
afternoon was this would allow the
members who serve this equivalent
benefits of other members who are
serving so they would all be treated the
same okay and I currently we do have a
space force in the state of New
Hampshire and I wouldn't want those
members to be treated in terms of
benefits housing Etc I'm just caring
about this now and the others all right
then I'll I will amend my vote to yay
okay representative is asked to move
that we make this put this in the
consent calendar with no objection we
will do that Madam Clerk
and
oh yes so the blurb or the the committee
report on this measure uh eruption
Mastermind uh sings that you made the
motion would you
and that brings us to
h
HB 330 uh two reps of runs you have a
motion for that one yes well I can make
a motion about to pass on HB
3 330.
330 is there a second for that
representative massimillo
SEC represent Massimo seconds
representative rhone's motion of OTP
representative Rollins who let would you
like to speak to your motion sure thank
you Mr chair
um I think we got a pretty good
understanding from the people that
testified in that it's extremely
important that we keep our numbers up in
the National Guard and as they do a lot
of things in the state as we've heard
throughout the committee so anything
that we can do to help them with the
recruiting I think and I think this is
an excellent idea as a starting point to
help them try to get closer to their
numbers
thank you representative Rollins
represent Massimo is the second term
would you like to speak to the motion
thank you representative
we have concurrence here would anyone
else like to speak to this motion
if not uh Madam clerk if you would once
again read the role of the motion is uh
OTP on hb330
okay
um
representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
representative of course that we are
beloveds early
representative gag yes
representative Monte
yes
chair of ogs as well
the count is
8 9 10 11 12 13.
13-0 with no objection we will also ask
that this be placed in the consent
calendar
thank you all for yesterday
representative Rollins
could you explain to the Freshman know
and understand what the consent calendar
is all about
sure if there's any question that um if
if a committee is we just did has
unanimous unanimity or near unanimity uh
on a bill it doesn't involve a financial
note and I do notice that hb330 does
have an FN
um so we may need we may need to uh
confirm whether or not we can we can put
that on consent if so that's something
we'll follow up on but uh definitely on
206 that will be on consent meaning all
the bills that the Committees are
unanimous on uh go on a calendar and
they're voted on mass uh as a block of
however many there are now in the past
any any member could ask or pull a bill
off of the consent calendar bring it to
the floor for a debate and a vote we
have changed the rules uh this time
around so in order to pull a bill off
the consent calendar rather than just
have one per person do it you would need
to we no need to have tent that is a new
rule for better for worse so if any of
you if you did see a bill not
necessarily from this committee but if
you saw a bill on on consent Connell you
thought deserve to be debated on the
floor you would need to find nine other
people and and get the names to the
clerk and then it would go to the floor
is that explain it
fairly well hopefully
anything else yes uh
representative Rollins well and and I
will we'll get that we'll get that done
I want to sit down together sure we'll
do we'll do it uh today good good
question Madam clerk thank you anything
else
if not we'll hopefully see everybody uh
next Friday and again we'll be in this
room in the morning and then reps all in
the afternoon
thank you